[Music]
ah
welcome back to the true jody podcast
sponsored by jim shark
uh today's guest
long time coming this has been a long
time i've always wanted to have dorian
on i i trained with you uh about 10
years ago
forgive me for not remembering well no
you mean
um i kind of looked 40 when i was 20.
but um
but it was an eye opener because i'd
always um mom and dad was a bodybuilder
in the 90s
and you know at a lower level you know
like the naba stuff yeah and he um he
always told me about like the great
bodybuilders and i remember distinctly
i'm going doria nate is the one he's the
one you want to listen to so i went on
youtube and i started watching these
videos and it like you go down the
rabbit hole
and i'm like wow this guy
because you had a total different vibe
to every other posing bodybuilder and
before i knew it i was watching blood
and guts and like i basically knew
everything about you so i went when i
trained with you
i always tell this story the same way i
say it because you about well how are we
all do you know
60 in april so you look [__]
unbelievable for your age
so you must have been about 50.
and you were still carrying quite a lot
of size back then i was yeah and you you
walked through the door and your back
walked through the door five minutes
later you were so like and that's when i
realized in that one moment i'm not
meant to be a bodybuilder because like
your genetics it really it really made
me realize okay
the density of muscle that you the
proportions and everything you just
didn't look like a normal guy and that
would have been 10 years ago so 2010
2011.
i mean that was
13 14 years after my competitive career
so i wasn't anywhere still near that's
what made what i used to be this is him
sort of over the hill i was probably
about
probably holding around 18 and a half
yeah
19 years
at that point and
off season in bodybuilding or somewhere
between 21 and 22 stone so
imagine another two stone two and a half
stone on top of that yeah but you could
i could see the building blocks of what
you'd created there was it was still
there which is obviously shrunk but
still it was
it was just out of
like a lot of people just think
bodybuilders take steroids and then boom
they they get big but like
the the proportions and the aesthetics
and everything that went into it it just
sort of struck me and then i trained
with you and then i was even more
convinced i wasn't supposed to be able
to this is what it takes day in day out
i mean
you know are you prepared to do that can
you do that and
ultimately your genetics is like is it
limited to how far you can go you know i
could practice basketball and play
basketball all day long from 10 years
old but i'll never be a basketball
player because i don't have the
characteristics of a basketball player
don't do yourself down like that i think
you could have a very good career yeah
i'm definitely a white man because i
can't jump right fair enough yeah that's
probably 19.
i got no coordination so i wouldn't be a
basketball player no matter how much i
practice so
with bodybuilding everybody can improve
that's that's the message but
not everybody can be a
professional bodybuilder or mr olympia
and you know talking about steroids
how many people in the world know how
many men are taking steroids it'll be in
the millions right so
there's only one
mr olympia there's only one person so
yes they are part of the game and they
do help a lot i guess um it was the
train and that that messed my head up by
the way it was what was it exactly so i
remember right he's got this machine the
temple gym
you put your arms back
naughty let's pull over
because that was one of your main things
that you were known for i was like what
is this like
and after the first whatever however
many i mean even the warm-up i was like
god his warm-ups are pretty and what
have i let myself yeah i was i was
starting to realize that so then was
this one on one so just to create a
little one
i do train
you know i coach people in various ways
one-on-one
in the gym and uh i got a platform that
i help people dy academy so i like
actually like
helping coaching people and probably
of all the aspects of bodybuilding
because many aspects you've got the
training you've got the nutrition you've
got the the chemical side you've got the
contest prep
but i loved the training and i loved to
find the best way to train and i had a
passion for it and i over the years
um
as well you know a lot of people know
but i logged every single workout so
every workout from 1983 to 1997 i got it
all logged down and
i you know i train a little bit more
frequently an extra day this week or
you know some change there and i would
be able to analyze it is this beneficial
is this not beneficial and
i had the theory of hit training from
arthur jones from mike mensah
so the theory appealed to me because it
was logical and that's the way my brain
works it works in logic and mathematics
and straight lines
so the theory was sound
but if the theory sounds great and it
doesn't work out in practice it doesn't
mean [__] so uh i analyzed it and i
noted if i train more frequently if i do
a bit too much then my progress was just
stopping and then i was cutting back and
uh i observed the people i trained many
people i've helped and it's it's always
the same story but it's kind of hard for
people to get in their mind
so little so little
it's little in time and volume but it's
very high in intensity yeah you find out
yeah you brutalize yourself for a very
short period of time and then you let
your body recover and overcompensate and
grow and that's the process that that
process is something that i think people
think they understand because they watch
a video like i could watch blood and
guts and go oh yeah i'll i'll do that
this is the training video that dorian
was very famous for because no one had
ever put out an authentic bodybuilding
workout like that they were all in
little stringers on the beach that's
exactly why i did it yeah it was
completely different because i you know
i you start as a fan right
and i look forward to watching these
vhs that came out road to the olympia
and the different
training and i'm like is this really the
way they train i don't think so i'm not
getting inspired by this so when i had a
chance to do it
and i realized why that happened
because at that time you know we all got
iphones and cameras and everything back
in the 80s and 90s you had to have a
professional camera crew to come and do
it and the camera crew want to do it
from their
perspective from their point where they
want the perfect lighting the perfect
angles and if you're going to take time
to do all that you're going to lose the
authenticity of the the workout so
i had a friend who was a photographer
kevin horton
i said kevin let's just hire a video
filming camera
well i want you to come in and i'm going
to train as normal i don't need to talk
to me i don't need to mess about with
lights or anything i just wanted to
capture
the workout and the intensity and the
weight and the feeling
and nobody cares about shades and angles
and lights they want to see
and i want people to watch that
training video
and get pumped up and want to go to the
gym and i obviously achieved that
because i've heard it a million times
like dorian i play that before i go to
that i've watched it i've worked i've
worn the tape out then i got the dvd and
i won the dvd out so i was really happy
with the results and uh i was watching
the playbacks
after we filmed it and i said
something's wrong with this
i said tell you what can you turn off
the color and just make it black and
white and he did that and i was like
that's it
yeah i got inspired by this uh you know
the raging bull the robert de niro
a boxing movie when it's all in black
and white it's just so much more gritty
and realistic and that's what i wanted
to put across and that helped your vibe
as well because what dorian had which
even though bodybuilding is a contest
where you're not competing actually
contact with each other you had this
intimidation factor and i could only
compare it to mike tyson or someone like
that it
the vibe you were giving off was like
i'm not yet a smile and be a model i'm
an athlete and this is my my profession
and you you put a completely different
slant on it than anyone else i've ever
seen yeah i mean the whole
enigma the the shadow and everything
like that could have been a well thought
out image and strategy but it wasn't it
was just me being me
and i was kind of introvert i didn't
like the limelight i mean it's part of
it you got to go on stage and do it but
that's that's once a year right um
so i didn't
want to show people what i was doing
and the guys in the gym that trained at
temple gym they'll tell you even the
guys that trained with me my training
partners they never saw me without a top
on they never saw me without a top one
until probably three or four weeks
before the olympia and i'd do a little
i'd invite a couple of people down from
the
bodybuilding community whose opinions i
respected because they knew what they
were looking at because they'd been you
know judging the mr olympia or they've
been they've seen the top guys they know
them they know what they're looking at
and i would you know three or four weeks
before i'd
invite them down and you know say what
you think and this and that but apart
from that
and i wasn't interested in if i took my
top off every day at the gym i would
just go oh yeah you're amazing you you
know you beat everybody you're in shape
now you don't need to do anymore i
didn't need to hear that from people
that didn't really know
what they're looking at i can't stress
enough right because i've trained and
i've done boxing i've done lots of
different training
i've never felt more exhausted and more
like wanting to quit
than when i trained with you and very
early on in the workout as well i
remember thinking
i'm on my fourth set of like whatever we
were going to do 60 and 20 sets how am i
feeling like i'm dying already and i
remember after the first machine was
done this noteless and the right into
your lats i i went beyond failure and
you were doing force reps with me and i
just remember thinking i'm going to
basically embarrass myself in front of
myself yeah because i want to quit right
now already and it just and i went back
to the gym you weren't gonna mate i
wouldn't let you know but i went back to
the gym the next week and all me made so
then i went lads we don't train hard we
think we do right but we're chatting
we're taking our time yeah we lift heavy
weight yeah we're not training hard the
focus is about the focus yeah you're in
there and you're just there and your
mind's inside the muscle nothing else
exists and you're pushing to the extreme
and
how hard you push is
is only a matter of motivation because
your mind
is the you know
it's the mind that fails before the body
and that's what i show people when they
come and train with me i show them
techniques show them the form
you know i show all that but it's
i often tell people look you
you were gonna you wanted to stop at 10
there
yeah but because i'm here because i'm
shouting out and i'm pushing you you did
14 you did 15. you did it
yeah you lift i didn't lift it for you
but i motivated you so it's obviously a
matter of motivation how far you're
going to push and for me
bodybuilding was a way to change my life
and it was
the mentality i put myself in is that
i'm fighting for my life here and when i
turn pro i'm like the other guys are
trying to take food off my table off my
family off my kids and i'm gonna there
for a battle i'm not gonna bear to smile
i just you know i'm going there to win
the contests and
that was my frame of mind so
and it was to my advantage that i was in
the uk i was in this little hole in the
ground in in birmingham and nobody saw
me all year round so this guy that you
can't see somehow
you know it's building like
fear up in your mind because you can't
see me doing anything about him
you're spoken about but no one sees you
it's almost like a fictional character
who shows up once a year and just steals
dreams yeah it's like crushes people and
goes back home to his you know
that back in his basement but that's i
mean people ask me like
could you be the shadow now these days
uh probably not
you know you need to be visible to you
know to generate a living and everything
now where then i just had to be in the
magazines and that i would do
once a year after i competed i was in
shape i'd do all you know all the shoots
all the interview everything in a week
period in los angeles and then i'll
disappear again
it's the power of the mind with you
that's one thing that really struck me
and i was i was really into mma when i
was learning about you as well and i
remember thinking this is like a fight a
mentality in bodybuilding i think so
yeah i think uh
i had a different mentality and actually
i did the first
sports slash exercise type of thing i
was doing was when i was a kid i was
doing karate
so i think that always stayed with me
even my posing if you watch it's a
little bit
marshall compared to the other guys a
bit more
flowing and stuff mine's a bit like oh
it's like i'm here
you know and that reflected my physique
and my persona which is important when
you're presenting yourself i wasn't
a frank zane or a bob paris or anything
like that i was
you know big powerful strong guys so
that had to come across in the
presentation yeah and like just to be
clear for those who don't know anything
about bodybuilding you
i feel like there's two bodybuilders who
had a huge impact compared to everyone
else one is arnold and one is you arnold
sort of started it and you changed it
and it was like those two pivotal
important moments in the game
um do you agree with that my mentality
was
in stages
you know i um
i wanted to be the best in the uk and i
wanted to change my life
i kind of
i did a little bodybuilding when i was
at school and left school and my life
was very
chaotic i left home at 16 and
i got in a bit of trouble i was in a
detention center and in there they had
weights
and there were 300 guys in there
and i quickly realized i got the best
physique in here like naturally and i'm
pretty much the strongest guy in here so
this is something i can do that's
positive for my life and i didn't know
at that point that would lead to being
mr olympia and everything i just knew if
i put my energy into something positive
i would get something positive back
maybe i'll win some contests maybe i'll
oh maybe i can open my own gym one day
or something that was how it started
yeah the 90s were so different like
everyone's sort of combat sport are the
thing now but my dad's here on the night
he's yours was like if you weren't a
bodybuilder you were no one like my dad
i think it was a peak of interest in
bodybuilding and now
you know in the 90s we had bodybuilding
we didn't have
fitness crossfit
men's physique we didn't have mma all
these other
avenues that people might take now the
those kind of guys were all going into
bodybuilding ever wanted to be a
bodybuilder in the 80s and 90s it was
the peak of the popularity although
i suppose the industry
as a whole is bigger now but it's it's
much more diverse it's not just
bodybuilders many more categories
involved there was kind of an obsession
i think in the 90s as well with people
changing their bodies be that sort of
bodybuilding in the gym or plastic
surgery and those kind of things and
that those two things seem to coincide a
bit as well well if you look at the
movers what were popular in the baywatch
the late 80s i mean you you got all the
arnold's movies they started with conan
and the terminator then you got stallone
so everybody wanted to you know build
their physique uh now it's it's it's a
bit different you know you know when
you're talking about um getting into
trouble and
um i'm aware you lost your father at a
young age and then you and your mother
weren't that particularly close yeah i
wondered if if that
difficulty that you had growing up sort
of gave you that mental strength that
you had because we always have our
fighter
take
oozman of the ufc right now like some
people who've had a rough start in life
they seem to be able to go to another
level that people who've maybe been
muddy cuddled just conquered absolutely
absolutely i remember seeing uh
um not so long ago
mike tyson's son on the pads and he you
know he looked wow a bit tyson-esque you
know yeah and they asked tyson you know
when he make a champion he's like no way
like why not
because he hasn't lived my life he's
he's been comfortable
so he's not he's not going to be able to
do it he's not going to have that inside
him and uh yeah i didn't have a lot of
options and i felt i had to fight
for everything and
i think my dad dying young my mom not
really being able to
cope with me or
you know with my
anger and confusion and everything like
that
that was definitely a driving force and
i had to grow up
and look after myself pretty quick you
know i was
16 and i was out on the street living up
you know friends houses or something and
get my own little place and i got to
look after myself there's nobody else
that i can
fall back on
so you know that gives you
kind of um
you're either going to make it or you're
going to
you're going to fall and when i was in
the detention center it was like a
crossroads it's like which which way do
you want to go here you've had a taste
of this and
i don't belong here i don't i don't you
know
even the the
the prison officers are saying you don't
belong here well you're a very smart guy
i mean they were like you're an
intelligent guy you don't belong here
well i don't have any
paperwork to say i am but
i you know i got that innate kind of uh
you're a science television thing the
way you tried it i analyze everything i
analyze everything got that analytical
brain and i'm always asking questions
and i'm always wanting to know the truth
and i hate to think i don't know the
truth and someone's pulling the wool
over my eyes and i'm being fooled
um
and i you know i didn't there was no
such thing as the culture they've got
now you've got a nutritionist you've got
a coach you've got you know whatever
it's now that
kind of making bodybuilding into a team
sport for me it wasn't that team sport
it's a individual effort and i didn't
have a team i didn't want to have a team
i want to do it myself i'm if i win it's
i'm responsible if i lose i'm
responsible and i'm not saying i didn't
listen to anybody to any advice or any
information i'll get some from here some
from here some from you some from him
and then i would shift through it all
and see what made sense and ultimately
what works were there any key figures
that you sort of remember being
influential on you
uh yeah there was a guy um
called ron davis
he was the head of the efbb which is
english federation from ifbb which is
the federation that promotes mr olympia
so that's
you know that's the ultimate contest mr
olympia if you're a bodybuilder that's
there's only one contest that's
important that's it
and um so i went to do my first contest
after i'd been training for about a year
and a half
and i went to do a novice contest
and you know i went there thinking you
know i'm pretty good for a novice i
should
i feel fairly confident i can win this
qualifying contest then i want to go to
the
british championship novice championship
and win that and then the next year
maybe the you know
the british championship itself
um so i went on stage did my compulsory
poses that you have to do and then came
back off stage
and these guys were there these
officials from the you know and ron was
there
and they're like
hey who who are you where do you come
from i'm like i'm coming from birmingham
what are you doing in the novice class
you should be in the heavyweights i said
no no i'm not good enough for the
heavyweights yeah and they're
practically laughing at me
so it's not good enough do you know
you're probably the best heavyweight
we've got in the country right now not
good enough to be in a heavyweights mate
it's like and uh ryan had a gym in in
birmingham called muscle machine and
invited me down there to train and you
know basically told me i said you know
you could be mr olympia one day so he
knew he you know he recognized the
potential
and uh i trained there for a little
while but it was too
uh it was too civilized for me you know
i had office people come in to train on
their lunch break and you know i want to
spit on the floor and
growl and sweat and
just wasn't that environment so i went
you know i said thanks ron for your help
and everything but i got to go back i
got to go back to the ghetto i've got to
you know go back to my roots and
that energy
i'm scaring the people in here you know
so it wasn't the right place
you're loud when you train that's right
run you know whatever it takes i don't
know i'm not conscious about it i'm
pushing myself to the limit and if
you're doing that you're probably going
to make some noise
so ron
gave my confidence a little boost i
think that was more than anything
um
and there's a guy from birmingham as
well he had a supplement company called
tropicana he gave him my first
sponsorship which was 10 000 a year and
he again he said look i want to sponsor
you
when you go to america i think you're
going to do really well and if you get a
better offer than this like take it and
i'll stop it wherever you want to i
don't know so
it was a good guy that got behind me a
little bit in terms of guiding you
though like in terms of sort of mental
guidance and those kind of things was
there were you did you feel like you
were quite on your own when it came to
deciding yeah absolutely and you know
i'm not a coachable person i don't think
you know
because a coach would tell me to do that
and i'll be like why and you know
in the end i'd do my own thing anyway so
as far as training
and nutrition and all that stuff i
pretty much just worked it out myself so
it was just people that give me a little
bit of
encouragement really and i think um
because i lost my dad and i didn't have
a
male role model the guys in the
magazines or at least what was projected
in the magazines from the guys
they became all those my surrogate
fathers back then all the best
bodybuilders came from the states all
the contests were in the states the
industry was there were you not known
about in america absolutely nobody knew
me nobody nobody knew me so i'm going to
new york and i don't know anything about
new york where to go
where to train where to stay or anything
so i contacted the somebody from the
federation in england say look you know
i'm going over but i don't know and can
you introduce me to somebody i need
somewhere to train and all this stuff um
so he introduced me to the promoter and
the promoter came to pick me up at the
airport
and i saw him before he saw me and i was
like hey wayne
i'm i'm doing it oh oh
okay come on then
i said uh
i was looking for a black guy
you know what it is dorian is the name
that you could associate with that again
i'm saying why are you looking for a
black guy yeah he's like because you've
got a funny name
and up to this point all the good
bodybuilders from uk we're black so i
just assume you'll be black i'll say no
i'm sorry
i'm white you know
anyway it's a funny story he picked me
up
so he said you know we've
arranged the gym for you and we've
arranged accommodation there's a guy
who's got an apartment for you and all
that near the gym and it's all good yeah
so okay so it's 2 3 a.m in the morning i
mean i'm exhausted i'm like super
depleted
you know you know three percent body fat
dehydrating my face is like i'm
exhausted here quick question about this
you know like how bodybuilders are
traveling all the time yeah they're
obviously taking steroids steroids you
can't really get them through customs
i'm guessing yeah like
what what do they do when like well
actually in 1990 there was there was a
big thing in the in the states i think i
don't know when it was like 91 92
something like that
where
steroids became illegal it was big
hoo-ha because people in best baseball
were using it and baseball is the apple
and apple pie american clean
sport listen no clean no sport is clean
sports are about winning with highly
competitive individuals and they will do
whatever it takes to win in any sport
that same thing applies yeah
so at that point i just take it with me
in in
in the future i used to mail it over
ahead of time
i like that hope i don't get arrested
sorry yeah
um so i was with wayne we went
in his car
and uh go to the gym he said we're going
to meet the guy outside the gym and he's
going to take you to his apartment and
you're going to stay there i've got my
wife with me got my big bag with my
little oven cooker in there and
everything was like
everything i did was like a military
campaign you know tick this i got this i
got there i didn't want to leave
anything to chance yeah so we pull
outside this gym and there's a guy there
and it's like hi
i was like
what is up
so obviously the guy in the gym
having no respect for british
bodybuilders just ask is anyone in the
gym want to put this guy up like he's
coming from england bodybuilding
you know
so
then we're driving in new york and
wayne's telling me you're on the lower
east side he said it might look really
rough here but it's becoming you know
gentrified just like the east end of
london i guess
um
okay
he said i'll drop you off at the guy
here drops us off the building next door
is
crack house with police tape shut down
we go into this
apartment building it's got no lift so
i'm having to walk up the stairs i'm
exhausted it smells of piss
and we go into the apartment
and the bedroom door's open there's a
naked guy lying on the bed
and then he's got me this little room
with homoerotic pictures on the wall oh
god i don't think against homosexual
people but
it's not for you it's just not my thing
it's not not my environment you know
and uh this is the fault this is this
this is 1990 you know with the aids
thing and people didn't really
understand all what it was and how you
get it and everything and the guys like
would you like a tea or a coffee and my
wife's telling me
no no no no
she didn't want to drink from the cups
or anything you know so
i said mate i said i need to talk to you
i said i'm sorry yeah but you know i got
my contest coming up and everything i'm
trying to be polite as possible
um this living
area is not suitable for me i need to
get a hotel and need a hotel with a
kitchen apartment preferably and it's
like yeah i'll do that in the morning
i'm like mate i don't think you
understand you need to do that now get
on the phone and do that now so anyway
it's funny because he got me a hotel
it's called the chelsea hotel in chelsea
in
manhattan and uh as a teenager i was a
skinhead
skinhead and skinheads and punks in
birmingham they all stick together
because they couldn't get into any pubs
so there was one pub in birmingham all
skinheads all pogs went there so
i know all the story about sid vicious
uh from the sex pistols and sig vicious
killed his girlfriend nancy
in the chelsea hotel so i was like isn't
that weird of all the hotels so in my
life we always see these little
synchronicities sorry so you turn to
your wife and you go isn't it weird sid
vicious killed his wife here yeah
here we go yeah
so uh
that was it and then i went to the gym
in in new york
that was um
you know
uh look supposed to be looking after me
and i went there and i said i'm dorian
and listener yeah go and go and try and
then
and basically they were they were pretty
rude to me pretty rude and disrespectful
because
this guy from england here it's not good
still got your top one yeah i've still
got the top one training
then afterwards there's changing rooms
downstairs
and it's a little area with mirrors so i
could do my posing yeah so you know
after the workout stripped off started
doing posing i didn't know there was a
little camera up there that went to a tv
behind the desk upstairs
half the gyms come down the owner
everyone that works there that was
before not giving a [__]
oh like wow that you're amazing and blah
blah blah blah and then you know
the whole
atmosphere changed then anyway i went to
uh knight of champions
held in manhattan and the new york crowd
was very well known for being very vocal
i mean new yorkers are like that it's
they don't like they're going to tell
you
so i didn't really know what to expect
anyway came out and did my posing
initial posing and did my you know
unusually martial aggressive type pose
and i was banging my foot on the floor
when i did my cast and all this stuff
and uh it was quiet
and then slowly the whole audience
started going
dorian daria daria yeah they must have
been like who's this guy who's this guy
who's this guy got and then they just
started i was like okay the crowds the
crowds with me so i got second at that
contest to mohammed ben aziza
um
and wieder must have seen something in
me that was
unique because i got i got invited out
to venice california to do the shoots
for the wieder magazines at the gold's
gym and everybody build a stream at that
point that's you know you made it if you
get
so i got flown out to la and did my
first photo shoot out there how are you
feeling at this time sorry because i
know now you're telling it you're so
it's sort of like oh of course it's
during it but
back then this must have felt quite
different to you when you're real yeah
surreal you know so being in new york
was surreal that this place is i'm here
it's real new york and i've got second
in this contest flown out to uh l.a
it's all a bit of a whirlwind you know
and it's like feeling like wow
is this really happening as i've really
made i've been dreaming about this for
years and i'm you know i'm getting there
now were you overall do you think you
you were the kind of person who took
that in your stride at the time like was
this something where you were a little
bit like
hold on a minute what is going on here a
little bit yeah but it's happening so
fast right you know and um
then i did my first photo shoot in a
girls gym there
and they wanted me to wear sunglasses
and they used to spray the guys with
water bottles so it looks like they're
sweating and you know they hold these
weights and their pose and everything
i said i'm not wearing sunglasses good
thing i had a british photographer chris
lund so he could relate to me a little
bit because the americans never really
understood me why i'm not
that guy that's always wanted detention
why i'm not telling everyone how great i
am and all the time and all this stuff
they didn't get it you know
i said chris i'm wearing sunglasses man
i'm from birmingham train underground i
don't wear sunglasses
and i want to lift some real weights i
don't want to mess about with this stuff
let's lift some real weights so it's a
200 pound dumbbell i said mate oh how
about if i lift this and get a shot of
this i'll do a dumbbell row
it says can you lift that i see i can
lift it but i can't smile when i'm
lifting it mate and i can't hold it
there while you get the right angle i'll
get it up maybe you better
get the shot here
and uh he did that and that was my first
cover on the flex with a 200-pound
dumbbell um
you got blonde hair yeah yeah yeah yeah
like a mullet yeah i like that it's
funny because you and brian have very
similar approaches to photo shoots
actually yeah you either get it or you
don't well i i you know uh
kevin horton who's a friend of mine is
british so
we had a good relationship
much better than i had with the other
photographers
and people said how is dorian to do a
photo shoot he said it's [__]
miserable
it just doesn't want to be there it
doesn't want to do it
so get it as quick as you can you know
and um
so from that point forward
the whole way that they did the
bodybuilding photography changed because
i did this cover and i'm lifting a 200
pound dumbbell
and you can't get the same look by
lifting a lightweight i mean literally
the veins are sticking out my neck my
eyes are bulging
you can't pose that yeah
so they were like ah this is very
popular people like this and they just
started doing more and more of that as
well wow you were like the first
i was just me stubbornly being me right
you know and not being able to be
molded or manipulated and you know
everyone tried it was a very corny
bodybuilder yeah yeah yeah i mean
joey came to one of my photo shoots
remember you used to have flex which is
a hardcore bodybuilding and muscle and
fitness which was the more
mainstream and muscle and fitness always
had a guy and a girl on the front cover
so you know it appeals to everybody
let's get like a little skinny model and
a bodybuilder and she's on his shoulder
like yeah there's this kind of stuff so
dorian we're going to do a muscle and
fitness
shoot with you just go more mainstream
you know flex you like
okay but muscle fitness
and joe came actually i remember asking
joe what
joe why are you coming to the photo
shoots and all this stuff like if i was
you and i had all your money mate i'd be
on the beach and not bothering all this
nonsense here and he's like i'm not
gonna try and do his voice because
everyone does it better but
in a very distinctive voice um
he basically said look
i do what i love i love doing the
magazines i love bodybuilding and if i
if i'm not doing this what i'm going to
do i'm just going to die early or
something because i don't have a mission
so
i learned that from him and he was great
that like
you know joe weider trainer of champions
this was all a [__] myth you know
that he publicized he didn't train
anybody but he was very good with
photography and presentation and posing
was very good at
so he's like
dorian smile why i can't it's my wife
was there trying to get me to smile
extra the model everybody try and get
into smiles
show me your teeth there's something
wrong with your teeth there's nothing
wrong with my teeth man i just can't
do the smile and it's trying it's trying
in the end it just ah just let this guy
do what he wants
and that was you know from then that's
pretty much it this is still what you
want you can't you can't get him to do
what he doesn't want and you know if
you're mr olympia
you have that i guess that power to to
say no to things
um so yeah that was my first uh
trip out to uh to california which i say
is everybody build a stream at that
point you you've kind of made it if you
you get on the cover of the magazine
george just creeped into shots slightly
all right we're going to move that
camera over slightly i don't want to
just move that just like that
it's got big shoulders you know yeah
still got it half what they used to be
still got it so biggest but two cameras
that's a question i get asked so uh
especially by the young guys just twist
don't you
feel
bad now that you're smaller or don't you
wish she was still that guy and all that
stuff you know what what's the reply to
that because
no i'll be what i want to be you know
it's uh
i am smaller and lighter because i want
to be
not doing what i think
and this is where a lot of bodybuilders
get trapped that's kind of the that's
kind of the interesting aspect of it
isn't it i think a lot of people assume
that you wouldn't want to be you
wouldn't want to get that way they don't
they see it as a decline in that sense
either that or
the guy's thinking to himself
but everyone associates me with being mr
olympia or being this big bodybuilder
and if i'm not that guy anymore no one
will love me no one will follow me blah
blah blah blah blah you know um you know
people are following me now
for what i'm doing now as well as like
you did oh you know i've got people that
okay you did that in the past but a lot
of people are really appreciating what
i'm doing now and being inspired by it
because
it's about change
and
evolution
and you have to be willing to change in
life otherwise did you get stuck in a
mould and i think that's what happens
with a lot of bodybuilders i am a
bodybuilder i'm this guy i'm mr olympia
i'm this muscle guy
and i'm comfortable there
because i know that
but
to change sometimes you have to be
uncomfortable and you have to do and try
things that's outside your comfort zone
in order to
to grow and evolve and i think that's
what i've been
doing or trying to do
um
for some time now i broke the mold of
i'm just a bodybuilder um maybe that's
not
the best thing for me now anymore
um and carrying a lot of body weight is
not the best thing for you as you're
getting older that was actually one
thing i was going to ask because um
obviously you know that's a lot of
weight just to put on any joints in the
first place anything to the extreme is
not very healthy marathon running
triathlete running bodybuilding getting
kicked in the head in the mma all that
stuff i try to tell people you've got
competitive sports and you've got
exercise and sports and training for
health it's two different things
competitive sports is concerned with
only one thing and that's winning
and it's not necessarily you know we all
know exercise is good for your health
but at what point does it become
detrimental where you're
you know for instance endurance training
your body's producing so much free
radicals that you're just aging and
damaging yourselves
a little bit of moderate exercise great
for you but to the extreme no but
those guys that are doing it they're not
doing this
necessarily thinking this is my health
they're doing it as a challenge and as a
sport and there's a competition that
they want to win i'm not i'm not even
sure that anymore though as well is
because like
you the reason you became the the guy i
think is because you don't think like
the rest
and
when i look at a lot of lads i grew up
with who aspired to be bodybuilders or
wanted to just get massive
a lot of those guys didn't have a good
job didn't have a lot going for them and
their whole identity was well if i get
muscular at least i've got that and they
live for that and it becomes the only
thing about them that is unique i don't
think they get it like you know you're
spending all this time on how you look
but you're literally
you're pissing into the wind and wasting
most of your life away you're never
going to be mr olympia you're not even
going to make a money off of instagram
at this rate and
they they
some of them need a horse reality check
out the amount of lads i've met who've
spent
thousands of pounds on protein and
steroids and to win the crappiest little
trophy at a bodybuilding contest that no
one cares about because in their head
when they're on that stage they are you
they are but in reality it's like me
yeah
i don't know i was always very aware of
that because
you know i trained in the gym and all
the guys in the gym i could see what
they're doing
and uh
if you're gonna do bodybuilding to the
extreme
taking steroids carries some health
risks we can debate you know what that
is but it carries some risk
and um i saw people sacrificing
everything you know like
they're spending all their money on it
sacrificing time with their families
being in like
a bad mood and having a fight with their
wife and all that because getting ready
for mr
reel or whatever
you know uh is that a competitive one mr
real yeah i don't even know if it exists
but uh
just make an appointment uh no
disrespect to mr mr dudley or i don't
know it's like i i was very aware of
that and i actually put
a deadline on myself
i said all right i'm doing all this yeah
i'm doing all this i'm losing time and
focus
with my family i don't have any social
life i'm sacrificing that uh there's the
health risk
uh all these things is like all the
energy and focus you've only got so much
yeah
so
you put it all into that you don't have
much left for anything else
um
so i said all right
i'm british champion
i'm pro now technically i can compete as
pro i'm going to knight champions my
first pro show if i don't get in the top
five
i'm finished
i'm finished with competitive
bodybuilding i don't mean i i love to
train so i would always train and i know
i had a gym at that point temple gym
so i was saying like if it doesn't
competitive route doesn't go
then i need to put my time and focus
open some more gyms something like that
be involved but be realistic you can
relax and enjoy your life a little bit
more and spend more time in the family
and everything like that but fortunately
i got second and
that's history being realistic though
that is something that a lot of
delusional bodybuilders don't seem to
have it's like
this dream and
i i've been mates with so many of them
do you know what i mean and you're
thinking you look at them and you think
not a chance mate but it depends why
why you started bodybuilding and why you
wanted to build this physique
and a lot of time
you you're building armor
you're putting on a suit of armor and
everybody will then treat you
differently because you have some you
know you look stronger you look bigger
and everyone is then treating a little
bit different you feel better
yeah
you can't then give that up it's almost
like addictive well what if i go back to
be that little skinny guy that you were
or you think you were in your mind
nobody will respect me anymore nobody
loved me anymore or you know something
like that i think that's it so people
get caught in that mold
i call it being crystallized you know
um a lot of people just not bodybuilding
there's a lot of people in life get to
30 or 40 years old and this is who i am
and this is this is it ah this is who i
am
no you you know it's fluid right you
should be always
trying to learn more evolve more
that's why we're here right we're all
here for an experience to learn lessons
to
to have experiences and and change and
not here to go
from here to here and back again and in
a little
at least that's the way i look at it you
know
i wanted to
when i was a kid i never felt like
i fitted in i'm at school and i knew
this is more about indoctrination and
training than it is about learning
anything
and um i feel like i'm different i don't
fit in and i want to do something you
know bodybuilding came along and allowed
me to do that one of the things i wanted
to do when i was younger is i want to
travel the world as much as i can see as
many cultures and countries and with
bodybuilding allowed me to do that i've
been all around the world a few times
you know some places haven't been yet
and still want to go but
uh i never would have done that without
without bodybuilding and and that lack
of insecurity that you have because you
achieved your dreams of becoming mr
olympia and reached the top of the
mountain and had all the adulation
that's probably why i'm assuming you
don't care about having the same amount
of muscle when you're in your prime
because you proved your point you
achieved that and now you're going to do
something else physically
what i want now is to be functional to
be functional to be healthy
uh mobile
and you know want to look good to a
certain degree but i
don't need a bodybuilder's physique i
need to be in shape fairly lean i've got
some abs and you know
look okay 59 years old 59 years old with
all due respect [__] off come on
i'm comfortable with that yeah and uh my
my camera guys here came with us hiking
the other day
i said mate you as a rabbit
you stopped halfway up
i said mate it was a rabbit i said what
do you mean i was a rabbit i said me and
my mate other guys the same age as me
and his lifetime fitness who used to do
bodybuilding now does wrestling and
every time i come to uk we get together
and we do a good hike here
so i said we get young guys like you you
know in their 20s and we send them up
and if we can pass them on the way we're
still doing okay
so
that's that's how we gauge it you know
we're doing all right that was one
question i have because i'm i don't
really know that much about bodybuilding
but obviously noah and brian are no
little bits but there's kind of
for someone who doesn't look at it it's
very easy to jump to the conclusion
there's a lot of people standing on a
stage with
i'm i'm saying this honestly body
dysmorphia or people who basically need
to get too big or those kind of things
well that there is a degree of that yeah
because as i say this depends
why you started bodybuilding
uh when i was in the detention center as
a teenager
i already had the physique
and when i post up my physique when i
just started training a lot of people
are i'd like to look like that so i
already had a athletic physique nice abs
muscular
you know not big like a big bodybuilder
but a physique that a lot of people i
would like to look like that's a
beachbody i'd like to look like that so
i wasn't starting thinking i need to do
this because i'm small or i'm weak or i
don't have a good body
i was doing it
because this is a route to change my
life that's
that's what i had you know i had no
education not because i was stupid i
just after my father died i was before
my father died i guess i was doing quite
well at school but after that i just i
just lost all the interest so you've got
a partnership with him
um
not particularly my dad was not a guy
that was at home very much it was you
know sometimes there sometimes not there
but the thing is it was my dad yeah and
he was the male role model i remember
him teaching me to drive a car around
the field when i was like 11 years old
so i was driving a car at 11 years old
but i didn't own one until i was 25
because i didn't have any money to get a
car i was bodybuilding was catching the
bus everywhere all the time
so you know um
i wouldn't say it was super close but it
was my dad and you know everyone looks
up to their dad don't they absolutely
yeah um so after that i think i just
lost interest i didn't see the point and
i just knew that school was like
something's wrong yeah
you know and now i know something's
wrong it's uh
you're not really learning anything that
useful at school it's more about
trainings to be there from nine to four
because that's how you're going to fit
in with society they just give you
enough
um
you know to be a
functional worker basically
don't teach you about anything useful
like
what's money where does it come from how
do you manage it or you know things like
practical things like that you don't
learn at school so um
yeah i didn't feel like i fitted in i
wasn't interested in doing their exams
and stuff so i don't have you know
paperwork from school that would allow
me to get a good job or something like
that and then i ended up in a jail and i
know a lot of people that
be in and out for the rest of their
lives so i could have gone that route or
i could have gone the bodybuilding room
and
i knew that initial taste of being in
that place i was like i don't ever want
to come back here again
i'm a free spirit and i feel
you know you become a number right one
thing that always kind of fascinates me
and that you we were talking about
earlier as well is um
how trends are set within bodybuilding
and what i don't quite understand when
i'm looking at it as a novice or
whatever you want to call it
what makes a good aesthetic um well it's
a combination of factors to make
um a championship bodybuilder
it's a lot of people say to me oh look
at this guy this is a big ladder and
he'll make a good bodybuilder not
necessarily so
um
to be a good bodybuilder first you need
the skeletal structure that's your you
know
that's the frame of the building right
that you can't change
so you need relatively wide
clavicles to narrow a hips
preferably it looks more aesthetic and
you'll note that a lot you'll see this
in a lot of the champions
the leg length to torso the legs are
usually a bit longer because that looks
more aesthetic with the longer legs and
it gives more
you know uh taper more v shape to the
to the upper body are there certain
measurements that you would look for
like were you like well if you're a 28
inch waist or a 30 inch waist that's
that's good or are you've been so much
about measurements it's more like
what
what it looks like so you got the frame
and then
you need to build you need to have the
potential
and then you need to do it
to have
proportionate uh muscle mass
this even a champion body will have some
areas a little bit weaker than other
areas everyone has that
um
but generally speaking
um so
you have a length of muscle bellies all
over your body and that's genetically
determined so some people would have a
bicep that goes from here
all the way down right to the you know
right all the way down to here so the
longer the muscle building the more
potential it has
for for growth so you'll be looking for
somebody with that frame with
um you know proportionate um
muscle bellies
and
also the ability to
to get very lean is somewhat genetic as
well right i've got very
thin skin always been lean my kids are
the same my kids even before they
my son my daughter
no training they got abdominals
and that's somewhat genetic a lot of
people must really dislike your family
for that exactly isn't it i've seen your
son yeah and like yeah
and he is very similar to you he's
really a lot of crap
he's almost he's probably naturally
leaner than me he's not as big as me but
it's naturally even leaner than me
literally looks a couple of weeks away
from conscious shape without trying at
all for those who don't know there's
like is it seven poses you get judged on
there's uh seven compulsory poses the
you know the double bicep the lat spread
all that kind of stuff the seven of
those freestyle and then there's four
relaxed poses
strictly semi-relaxed poses from the
front from the side from the back so you
see all angles in a relaxed state and
then you see all those poses seven
compulsory poses some from the front
some from the side some from the back so
again you see all the muscles when when
they're posing so everyone has to do
this while they're called compulsory
obviously and you compare
mr a to mr b and c what are you
comparing when you because when i'm
looking at them you know it's the same
as when i first started watching
fighting i was a bit like great you hit
me in the face really well there it's
similar with this where it's like great
you've got muscle he's got muscle
to the to the layman it doesn't look all
that similar but i do understand there's
lots of news maybe so let's say me and
you are competing but you're better than
me in three poses
you could be
ten times better than me in three poses
but i beat you in four
it doesn't matter how badly you beat me
in those three you still only won three
it's like i don't know like rounds in
boxing or something well i won four so
i'll i'll be the winner so they're
looking for the best guy in each pose
and it's a combination of
proportions
size
and conditioning it's like if you've got
all those and put them in a pot and mix
them together
that's what you're looking for
and to my knowledge like to come out of
nowhere as you did and to get second in
your first olympia was very unheard of
at that point yeah yeah you know like
people like uh ronnie coleman jaya
cutler so many other big bodybuilders
took years to climb the ladder whereas
you just rocketed top two immediately
and then the guy who you pushed for the
title was like right that's enough for
that then
we won eight titles so yeah i mean at
that point he held the record
nothing too much to gain and everything
to lose if you go you know next year i
could have beaten him and he knew you
were just starting within that within
that then what are the conversations
like backstage or what are the
relationships like backstage because i
think a lot of people get an insight
into miss world or something like that
where it's considered to be this really
catty environment everyone sort of like
look at her hair or whatever
is is it comparable in in the men's
what's the competition like it's a
little bit like that well you know
guys can be a little friendly as well
but i wasn't
i i would be
polite and friendly if i see you
like normally
but
if we're backstage i'm not talking to
you i'm just focused i'm not your friend
at this point in time
i'm here to to win here to get the
trophy and the check and uh
you know afterwards all
so
i used to
be the last one to take off my uh track
suit backstage so i'll be playing little
mind games because i know everyone's
waiting to see you know so let them wait
could you feel the eyes yeah let them
wait so
so you're not really thinking about what
you're going to do on stage and how you
you you're looking at me
your energy is being taken by me so i'll
do that lee honey did it to me i
remember
uh
[Music]
he it said in the podcast that he used
to do this he said i did it to dorian
but i don't know if it affected him or
not but it did it did a little bit i
took the wind out your seals a bit i was
here he was over there and you know i
just happened to look up and he just
took his tracksuit off and
got his back out you know and his back
was super thick i was like oh [__]
i remember the day so i you know i
always used to do that to the guys
backstage not really you know if they
say hello to me i say hello but that
would be it the pinnacle or what a lot
of people felt like the pinnacle of
bodybuilding even was was that 1993 era
where you
put out those black and white
photographs
uh how long ago was that uh sorry
this was uh kevin
six weeks horton again
down i said can you come down
and take some pictures because i got
some from last year that you took in the
gym i want to stand in the same spot in
the gym the same lights and everything
so i've got
i used to do them at home you know every
week take pictures getting ready for a
contest and go to boots and wait for him
to be developed and all this stuff
so i said come down i wanted to take the
pictures in the same spot they took last
year
it took him a week after the contest so
i was in shape and i want to see how
compare so it was just for my reference
really
they said mate
i've developed them photos i said yeah
they look you said i'm going to bring
them down to you're not going to believe
this
and from the europe you know the two
years back-to-back is it's crazy the
difference
and um he said i'm going to send him to
the magazine to flex magazine that
wasn't the original plan it was just
just for me that's why i still got my
socks on if you look because i just
finished training took off my top took
over the bottoms left the socks on which
is a good thing because the floor and
temple gym was discussed in 30 anyway so
um and he sent them to the magazine
weeder put them in the magazine and by
the way weeda didn't like the pictures
he didn't get it he's like ah it's not
the correct lighting and the shadows i
said joe nobody gives a [__] about that
watch
and they became like
most iconic pictures of myself ever i
think but definitely those black and
white pictures they were six weeks out
from 93 yeah and that made did that make
the magazine before the olympia did
people know that that was what was going
to show up i think it came out just
around the time of the contest but the
thing was
uh peter mcguff was the editor of flex
magazine he was british and he was
writing for a small british magazine
when i became novice and our careers
went almost parallel oh yeah so peter
mcguff was a friend and he was the
editor of flex magazine and all the guys
that used to train in venice california
they used to go to the weeder offices
just you know just to be there and show
their faces and talk to the
the writers and go to see joe and all
that stuff so they're always popping in
so peter he said when they come in
he said um
have you seen the pictures of dorian
no no no no we've gotten what did what
does it look like i said i'd casually
just drop them on the table and watch
the face just drop like
demoralized from that point everyone was
looking
to get second place and that was first
for them
so they already mentally were beaten
before the contest not that it mattered
because physically they were going to
get beaten as well they'd never seen
anyone as
in condition with that kind of mass yeah
you know i don't know what you weighed
on stage that year but it was late on
stage about actually those black and
white photos always about 270 something
so i don't know what that is 19 and
something 19 or something
and on stage i was
257 258 so
um
a lot of people like that physique that
i had with the black and white because
it's bigger and fuller but i wanted to
be super shredded as well so i always
used to sacrifice a little size and
fullness to get that yeah uh shape as
well but even on stage it was you know
nobody had seen that before really and
and what he needed what was he like a
240 guy and you know 245 something like
that so we've gone up with another 10 12
pounds and leaner you know lean lean
muscle tissue same height so
you know that was accepted
they called me the game changer from
that point because it was before dorian
and after dorian whether that's a good
or a bad thing
because a lot of people were trying to
get big like myself and ronnie coleman
who followed me was even bigger a lot of
people trying to achieve that
but they're not putting the work that
you know they they're getting the body
weight they're getting the size but it's
not the same it's not the same you see
today's bodybuilders have size or even
for the last 15 years the size has been
there but the conditioning
it's not been there at all no because to
get that kind of condition and you've
got to come down and the body weight and
lose some of that size which they don't
want to do now and it's kind of i guess
the standard now is not so high
so
you know nobody needs to really do that
i mean you can tell now when i went to a
competition back then
even the guys with a tracksuit on zipped
up to their chin
i would know who's in shape oh by the
face because the face will be super
drawn here and see the muscles in the
side of the jaw that
face will be sunken in that guy's you
can see he's in shape but now the guy's
around and happy and
rounded up yeah yeah yeah they're
smiling
around as well because they've got those
sort of distended
yeah this is from uh
nobody really knows exactly what that is
but i started using insulin
as an anabolic
96 97 the last two years i was competing
um
and my stomach just started to get a
little bit distended so i think this is
this is the cause is that called
bubblegum yeah in insulin is a strange
one uh from what i from what i
understand about because obviously it's
a diabetic
drug that and i'm guessing what you guys
were doing was trying to get your body
to absorb more nutrients and more the
insulin in a way is an anabolic hormone
so if you mix it with growth hormone and
steroids theoretically
it you know it works in an anabolic way
but uh
i tell people that i coach and i help
now and advise i said look i'm always
honest i tell you the truth yes i used
insulin was it a positive in my mind
no it wasn't because you'd start to lose
a little bit of the quality and
not to mention the negative health
effects you know diabetics that use
insulin i think they have like
10 years less life expectancy wow so if
you're using insulin and steroids and
other things all together it's
becoming a ticking time one yeah there's
a lot of the older you get the older you
get the more
the less that you know
let's say when i was 20 years old yeah i
could go out and get totally hammered
pissed drink a bottle of vodka and the
next day i'll probably be all right or
the day after that i'll be fine if i did
it now i'd be destroyed i wouldn't i'd
be a weak yeah so your body can't
tolerate this kind of stress as you get
older yeah um so we're seeing a lot of
heart attacks and stuff with
bodybuilders now in the 40s and 50s i
mean it's happened always since the 90s
has been a few guys mike mazzaretto that
competed against me had a triple bypass
at 38
and died at 48 so it you know it's there
but it's getting more and more frequent
now i think yeah i wrote down a few
names that i wanted to bring up because
it it feels like or especially i got a
list of 50 when i did a podcast last
week with this medical expert and
there's 50 pros that i know about that's
just pros that have died what about
amateurs what about guys that never
compete well yeah like um i don't know
if you know this guy but um
back in the 90s there was a guy called
andy holmby yeah british guy i competed
against him in the
british championship 1998 he was
light heavyweight i think yeah my dad
well he was my dad's best friend
actually but my dad always said like
this is a young guy wasn't it yeah he
was 20 early 20s he died backstage or
something i think
because of the dehydration
that's that's diuretic use yeah
some guys and girls
use diuretics to lose body water um
and you lose a lot of electrolytes
electrolytes regulate heartbeat so if
they get really out of whack
mohammad bin aziza that
beat me in my first pro show he died on
a european tour um
from basically his whole body started
cramping up including his heart and he
had a heart attack
very
early thirties i think so this process
that you guys go through i don't think
people understand who see it on stage
they just think you know you inject
steroids you get on stage but like
there's the
obviously there's the bulking then you
change drugs you you take cutting drugs
i guess that are different and then
um then if you're in using i don't know
if insulin is a part of that but the
fact that you then have to take all of
the water out of your body
and uh i went to a bodybuilding contest
once and i seen this kid like he he was
like lying there before getting on stage
just drained
and he was getting like these
lucas tablets and a shot of whiskey
before he went on stage and i'm like
this is absolutely mental this um like
what is that process like doing all
these
well because lawrence was asking me
about trend before we came on and i'm
like actually trends almost a whole
other thing now what is it what is that
even tremble owns a anabolic steroid
that um
see a lot
a lot of anabolic steroids aromatize
what that means is um because estrogen
which is a female hormone and
testosterone it's a male hormone
they're fairly similar yeah
so
if you're putting testosterone from
outside so your levels are going right
up male hormone levels your body can
actually convert some of that
to estrogen so the estrogen comes up as
well so it's trying to keep a bit of a
balance right but not all steroids do
that some of them don't aromatize to
estrogen uh trenbolone being being one
of them is that considered a positive or
negative because then i was considered
to be a positive before a contest
because if your estrogen levels are high
you tend to hold more body fat and more
water a bit softer right it's a female
hormone
um so tremble on
we were using that in a form called
parabolon
came in from france
in 76 milligrams
and
i'd probably use two of those a week two
or three a week was like
accepted back then that that would be
the maximum so around 200 milligrams
because it's quite powerful and
potentially a little bit toxic
guys are coming to me now that don't
even compete and then so i'm on 800
milligrams of trend i'm like
where did you get this where do you get
this information from like
it's it's crazy
you know the internet
is a source of information which
information is good but you got
a lot of information well that's what
we've done all of it's good a lot of
it's bad yeah we were talking about this
before weren't we because part of the
part of my research i ended up on tick
tock uh and no one ever wants to say
that when they're doing research but the
but the point with that was that there
was a guy on um tick tock who was
basically he's a bodybuilder and he had
his own bodybuilding account and i i
think
he hadn't you know he wasn't
particularly famous but he was saying
he was kind of beyond his peak and now
it was time for him to come clean about
a couple of things
and one of them was about tren and he
said he had a gyno problem and these
kind of things as a i guess as a side
effect of that and that it came with a
lot of side effects and he felt that
there was a lot of people on tiktok
instagram all these places just
advocating for the use of this stuff not
really talking responsibly about it and
he said it really concerned him because
i mean yeah i think
each generation of bodybuilders
are pushing the chemical envelope a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more it certainly looks that
way on stage yeah and what you know what
i'm told by people that compete or even
don't compete they're just taking it
recreationally they're taking uh i'm
said mate you're taking more than i took
from mr olympia so
i don't think you need that and uh
recreation
you're getting the benefit that you want
the recovery the muscle building right
with trying to minimize the negative
effects
and there's going to be a certain point
where you're not really getting any more
positive effects anyway it's like a
glass of water once it's full it's full
you can't use it it's just spilling over
then so
then you just put more stress on your
body for no benefit is that placebo
almost then for some people
um
i think so and then they're holding more
water it's not really muscle that's why
the physiques are looking soft but to
someone like me an everyday person if
someone's holding more water i'm like
[__] hell you look good like we don't
really know the difference down the
street i get a lot of people asking me
for advice and i always say to them like
me personally my advice to you unless
you're competing don't take any steroids
unless you're like
past 40 and your testosterone is low and
that's hormone replacement that's a
different story that's
that's good for your health if your
testosterone is low
and you put it back to you know optimal
levels optimal where you would be when
it's 25 30 and you're like 45 50 years
old it has tremendous health benefits
but at
super high levels
it's not that's an interesting angle as
well the testosterone replacement
therapy yeah
like
men have this period of their life where
things stop working as well as they used
to and and things like uh people call it
a midlife crisis but often it is just
like when your hormone levels are out of
whack and you've been used to a certain
level of pep in your step i guess
you're not feeling as good so that that
way it can really help men feel like
it's not just it's not that you're just
not feeling so good
um depression i guess as well depression
arthritis diabetes heart problems
all these things can be improved by
taking the you know testosterone
replacement amounts so
in that
context
is very healthy for people there's
a book that i read it was in french at
first now it's an english ageless man
and there's a french doctor in there
that's been prescribing testosterone and
other androgens for for decades and it's
got all the case
studies of all the you know
uh
health problems that people had that it
was basically able to fix
with testosterone but testosterone is
no profit in it for drug companies so
they'd rather you take some arthritis
drugs and some insulin and some
antidepressants and some of this and
some viagra you know all that stuff
together yeah it's more profitable for
you when guys get older though like
no offense to any of the elderly men out
there but you know you are a sh i mean
you're speaking to someone who's almost
60. no but then but i'm not talking
about dorian i don't feel like i'm sick
yeah exactly that's what we might say
you know when you see those guys who are
getting older the man boobs are coming
in things on
like and they can't be bothered to get
out of bed and do the same thing so
that's motivation yeah and a bit of
you know testosterone in them it would
change the game but like you say it
isn't advertised
by the companies who can make money off
of it because it's yeah you got maybe
you'd have to go to a private clinic or
something even your
gp is gonna probably frown upon it and
say no no no you don't need it yeah even
if you're
you know there's a there's a
parameters right your testosterone
should be between
whatever 200 and a thousand
so if it's
201 i'm okay
and you won't prescribe it to me i gotta
be
199 and then you'll give it to me so if
you're 200 or 250 or 300 it's not
optimal
you know you're not functioning
optimally you want to be up near the the
top of the range
um
and there's this
bit of a stigma about it because it's a
male hormone testosterone steroids
bodybuilders
but
women are on hormone replacement and
they're you know improving their quality
of life
with that
it's this idea that it's cheating and
it's like well not you're not we're not
cheating anyone if we do this later on
in life as men it's just having a better
quality of life and better health yeah
what's wrong with that is it cheating
taking insulin is it cheating taking
thyroid if your thyroid's not working
you're not producing enough testosterone
so do you still take any yeah i take
replacement
therapy if i don't it'll be too low
because i mean it happens anyway to to
men as they get older i thought i
accelerated mine because i was taking
steroids for bodybuilders so it
suppresses your own levels and it's hard
to get them to bounce back after
using it for years because i'm looking
at you at 60 years old thinking bloody
hell i wonder what he's doing
yeah but i mean testosterone flight
instrument is just part of it i got a
whole regime for my health i do
um
breathing exercises i do meditation i do
stretching i do cardio exercise i go in
the sun i walk barefoot on the floor
like
so many things i do to look after myself
because i did this sport which is
what i wanted to do and i don't have any
regrets or anything like that but it was
hard on my body
so now i'm being kind to my body you
know it's a very extreme
lifestyle
and now i feel like i'm more balanced
i'm balancing everything rather than
being in this extreme
mode when did you feel more in touch
with your body
after i started doing psychedelics
i did psychedelics and i got messages
when i did it it's the best answer i
think you're uh
your body's a bit messed up mate you've
bettered it about you need to straighten
it out and be more kind to it and uh
i i remember going to
the chiropractor or osteopath i'm not
sure in spain i was go like probably
twice a month for an adjustment because
it was a bit tight here a bit tight
there and all that
and then i had this vision like you need
to
do something different maybe yoga or
something and then i went to see him and
he's like
you ever tried yoga i said no it's funny
to say that because i've been thinking
about it it's not funny you never saw me
since that day i've never been back to
see him because i don't need to go
anymore because
i did this i did yoga and it was like
really
imagine i i couldn't even stand on one
foot without like wobbling and falling
over because i had no balance never
trained for balance to train for power
you're squatting your dead lift your leg
two legs and you push and saw power so
it was challenging and
all my fascia around my hips and my back
and everything was super tight because
it bloody needed to be to hold me
together in all you know all that that
kind of training and uh i remember i was
doing yoga and stretching and they say
you know yoga just go to your limit and
don't push but
you know this is
it's inside me isn't it to push a little
bit so i would feel like my fascia was
burning like i was on fire even though i
was feeling like nauseous and stuff
uh after a while it just got
looser and softer and i was able to i
couldn't even turn when i drove my car i
used to look in the mirror
instead of like turning because i
couldn't
i couldn't turn so that's i'm like
i need my body for what i need now my
this is the only vehicle you've got to
experience your life in here and if it's
if you're in pain and you can't really
function properly is your quality of
life
goes down
yeah we've kind of skipped the head
because you you probably were in a lot
of pain post bodybuilding because of
what you
eventually the injuries that you come up
against in bodybuilding as well i wasn't
in a lot of pain i um i had a bicep tear
and a tricep tendon tear during my
career so that that they were injured
but they were healed and they're a bit
weak
um
and my left shoulder was a bit injured
i guess the tendons were a bit frayed
and damaged uh from all this super heavy
training and then i was doing some
mma with some friends of mine and
wrestling and i fell on my shoulder and
just snapped the suit the the rotor cuff
and i had two surgeries to try and fix
it and it wouldn't fix so i said okay
that's it it doesn't hurt me
um it's just very weak i can't do any
kind of pushing or overhead stuff it's
very weak
so i guess it was made it was partially
damaged from my career and then i
finished it off doing something else
and uh a year ago
i was mountain biking fell off my
mountain bike and i must have put my
hand out to catch the four and it
totally dislocated this shoulder tore
tendons i tore ligaments and they wanted
to do surgery on it but i said i'm not
had surgery before it's painful it's
time out i don't want to do it um
so i've just rehabbed it and
strengthened it as much as i can so i've
got injuries so it's a bit limited if i
want to you know if i wanted to train
heavy i can't do it
you know i still like to train a bit
heavy but i can't and i accept it but i
can do everything else you know i can
swim i can do yoga i can do politics
biking
whatever and like training and cardio so
that's all i need now i'm not really in
pain i was just a bit like
not severe pain but i had tightness in
my back and things like that and that
tightness in my hips i remember having a
conversation with the osteopath and he
said you know when men were more
primitive
and women used to sit in the squat all
the time you know women just watched if
you look at india they'd sit in a squat
and wash the clothes by the river and
all that guys would sit around a
campfire and a squat and all that
i was thinking how i used to squat
four or five hundred pounds with my ass
on the floor i'm sure i can and i got
down into squat and it's like oh it's
all tight and everything yeah okay so i
need to work on that so uh
my body's just more functional now how
old were you when you had your last
bodybuilding contest i was 35
so i retired when i was 36.
um young in it it's a young man's sport
most sports are you putting your body
under a lot of stress um
so guys are competing a bit older now a
lot of them are actually yeah a lot of
them in their like 40s and still well
obviously there was sean rhoden who won
mr olympia 45 44 and he died at 46.
that must have been
a bit of a shock in the community when
someone saw recently the world champion
it's a shock because there's a mr
olympia right um
and there was a guy
oh sorry i can't remember his second
name from new york george
he died
in the hotel before the contest wow
so it was like uh you know double whammy
but there's you know
uh
the bodybuilding lifestyle and the drug
taking and everything affects your
vascular system
and the viscosity of the blood and
everything and then there's something
else around now i don't know if i can
mention it but yeah you mentioned
anything you want uh you know
this one that people are doing i want to
say it because i don't get this thing
pulled over sure i understand what
you're saying yeah right yeah but this
also
does you get it twice the v
all right yeah if you're not
if you're not veed if you don't got your
v card yeah
and we can go down the rabbit hole with
that maybe at some point uh you know
you got 110 105 fifa football players
that have collapsed on the pitch
fit young guys
after
the thing yeah um it's not true yeah
rugby players football players athletes
i've seen that i've seen a report of
like
um how many people had uh died in
america within like you know short time
after having it yeah but obviously
it doesn't fit the narrative to report
on that right now
no but it's coming out now the cdc are
basically saying
oops we're sorry all those covered uh
deaths that we put down to covet you
know what ninety percent was already
dying from something else
so
that's coming out
who now are admitting that
covid
is no more dangerous than a normal flu
that we get every year there's no more
deaths than we have every year so
it's a huge uh
it's a huge scam and it's
i don't think this truth is gonna
be able to be stopped coming out the
media's doing their best to not cover it
while it's leaking out yeah well we're
recording this on a day where boris
johnson's bringing in um new
uh restrictions or whatever and this uh
within a week of uh all coming out that
they were having parties last christmas
well yeah they're straight celebrating
well because they they know
right you know they'll wear the masks in
public
but in private they won't yeah there's a
video of that girl
first of all the virus is not that
dangerous and secondly the mask does
[__] all anyway apart from
make it worse because you're breathing
in your own toxins
so you
people are getting pneumonia and stuff
because they're wearing these dirty
masks all day and they're not breathing
properly people are forced to wear masks
now to work yeah to go to work they
don't have any choice if they want to
keep the job they've got all day
wear this mask and these blue masks that
everyone's wearing
go check out the
big box
that the little boxes come in on the
side of the box it says this will not
protect you from any virus including
coronavirus and
you're all wearing them
yeah it tells you
well i mean the muscular
harris sort of is you know the
second uh
after the senior guy um
she i just saw a video today and she's
saying
she's telling people that they still
don't get it
85 percent of the people now in the
hospital with kovid are vaccinated
so it doesn't protect you from anything
it's likely to make you sicker
so this is coming from their you know
their own mouths i mean i think the the
the lack of belief in the government is
finally starting to get to that point
now where the regular people who
followed all the rules and haven't been
skeptical from the start are now at that
point i think a lot of people like you
probably from the get-go were skeptical
i know i knew i knew
what was going on from day one yeah
because i knew that this uh new world
order globalist plan i hadn't known
about it for 20 years since i
met david ike in birmingham
you know so how did you so um
before you met david ike were you kind
of already
uh into into that uh i already
historically sense that things are not
right right but i didn't know exactly
the way the world works with the you
know secret societies and families
controlling
uh mostly everything i learned that long
time ago and i learned what the ultimate
end goal is
is to have a one world system one world
government army
uh
digital basically a technological form
of communism
right okay
that's the plan for us to have no
freedoms no freedom of movement and
finances and so on and also
dramatically reduce the world population
when you say communism what you mean is
kind of um because i don't know that
much about this you mean kind of
dysfunctional communism that we saw
before sort of some people at the top
creaming off and everyone else sort of
yes uh
though i think it's
what what i've learned in the last
couple years is how easy that is to
actually put in place i always thought
when i was listening to david or any any
conspiracy
theorist
the thing is that where does that term
come from conspiracy theorists yeah yeah
it's actually not theories or provable
facts of these things i mean the problem
with david like obviously
it can make it publicly very difficult i
think to to have um sort of a reason
debate in
you know
main stream
nobody's right on anything and david
dyke's just a researcher researchers
yeah there's a lot of people out there i
think he makes jumps though and that's
the thing what i'm saying is i'm not
saying look i've i've we've had him on
the podcast and when he did 9 11 i
couldn't argue with the words david
david didn't do 911 it was someone else
but you know the point is is
there's certain jumps he makes and
especially when corvid hit and he was
pushing it down to
um the the telephone change um 5g yeah
right
are very of basic that the telephone
change yeah
but but um
this is the thing is
a lot of the things david alex said back
in the day as much as he might have come
up with things i don't agree with
this vaccine passport and all of that is
one step closer to
like that inevitable id card and um and
what the the thing here digital like
digital control yeah so the the idea is
that all your financial records medical
records travel
all that will be digital mm-hmm and
within your traffic and yourself right
in your body and one of his theories
that um was the totalitarian tiptoe
about how
you know you can't get um the public to
you know buy into everything immediately
you've got to have an end goal and
you've got to baby feed them you know
like small steps at one time and get
them there and i do feel like in this
last two years i have been i always
wondered when i went back and watched
the 911 documentaries about you know was
it a control demolition and all of that
and i i you know i believe that there
was there was some shady [__] going on
around it um
and i've always wondered like would i
spot when something
like that happened as an adult and now
this has happened the last two years i'm
not saying that kovid is um something
yeah it's certainly a real thing in my
opinion but what i mean is the
government have used it to their own
benefit clearly to gain as much power as
possible and they do it just like they
did for 911 they do it in the name of
the disaster yeah but the problem is is
when the when the
when the event is over they never give
back the power that's happening
and we're in a position now where there
are people in australia being put into
uh corvid camps there are in germany
there are people being arrested on the
street for not having a core video if
you told people this would happen 10
years ago
you're crazy part of the reason it's
happening
is on a spiritual level because
a lot of people are waking up now a lot
of people are questioning things where
before they didn't
and it's a time
in human evolution where people are
going to wake up and become more aware
and realize
the system's not to their benefit so
they've got to kind of
shut that down before it gets too much
momentum and this was something that 20
years ago you sort of took an interest
in is that something you've kind of was
there a moment though right like i think
i had a crisis when i
kind of finished bodybuilding because
that's all i did that's all i knew this
all my energy going into that and then
[__] what i'm gonna do now it wasn't
even planned my retirement because i did
it
with an injury and some things happened
in my personal life as well i lost
somebody very close to me and i got
divorced a lot of stuff was going on it
just made me question everything so i
started reading and thinking and
studying everything and i came across
i came across a lot of
stuff that were really eye-opening and
like wow the world is not
the way i thought it was
were you um were you always spiritual
were you always someone uh who kind of
questioned things like that or is there
no not really much of that always been
somebody that
is
hard to control and always asking
questions and not following
but within that is there a spiritual
element to to you or around do you think
there's always been mirror is that
something you've nurtured after
bodybuilding it's been nurtured but i
think everybody's got it inside of them
um
i i think we're all aware that's
something bigger than
the physical world that we're
perceiving and picking up there's
something outside of that i don't want
to call it god or
universe or whatever you want to call it
what do what do you would you put a word
on that i guess i don't really like the
word god because i associate it with
them when i was at school and
tell you there's this guy up in the sky
is going to punish you if you don't do
what i want you to do basically uh so
maybe there's a bit of a negative i
still feel with that so i just call it
you know the the universe whatever
actually you know we're all part of it
and from psychedelics i've
learned this clearly that
everything's everything it's all we're
all part you know we're all
we're all part of it because that's what
you were talking about
have you done ayahuasca and done a
ceremony for that as well
where did you uh where did you do i did
it in spain initially and then uh you
know i told
brian rose on london reel about it and
we did the podcast and it was very
popular and then he went to try it at
this place out in costa rica saltara
and they got in touch with me and
said anytime you want to come out here
and do you know do the ceremonies at
this place
you're welcome to come out and i said
thank you
then they called me back and they said
you know what we had another idea
instead of you coming to do it
why don't you come out and headline a
camp and
dorian yates ios camp and we get people
from the fitness industry and stuff like
that or you know that follow you that
could be also interested um so we've put
three com camps on out there so far like
20 people in the group and uh
i guess people came
that maybe were curious but thinking
maybe it's not for me because that's
maybe some far out hippie stuff and i'm
a bodybuilder i'm in from the gym but
hey
i'm i'm curious about it and dorian's
doing it so
they came because of that and i've seen
you know people literally change their
lives for for the better from i know
i know a guy who's like as blokey as a
guy can get right like um he come back
into my gym
and he told me he was going to do this
um dmt trip
and
he come back and he went brian you're
not going to believe it and like he was
like he had this different look
different complete attitude
and he was like
i just i've cried and i've cried and he
went back to his girlfriend and he was
like i'm so sorry for the way i've been
treating you he stopped smoking he he he
said
uh i spoke there
god or whatever it was and and like this
is a guy who's like the last person i
ever expected have an epiphany and like
all of a sudden he's coming up with all
this and more like he's literally tears
running down his eyes when he's talking
about this experience he had and that
was when i was like bloody hell if i can
save you like
you you want to try this one you will be
changed and you will see everything from
a different perspective what was your
experience like then
every time it's a little bit different
but that was the main thing i mean uh my
first experience
i was laughing
because i was like wow
this is it this like it's like i knew
everything i couldn't the thing is you
can't retain all of it with dmt is very
quick
well ayahuasca is dmt but it's mixed
with another compound so it lasts for
hours so it's kind of slower you can get
a bit more from it
um but with the
with dmt i saw like
everything's one thing it's all
connected
and this life is just a little
dream
and don't take it seriously and i was
literally pissing myself laughing like
that's it you bastards and i've been
getting stressed and worried and
it's all just a little game and you
never die you just you know just playing
a role now and then you go somewhere
else and
um
you know i still forget that sometimes
because i'm here i'm doing this you know
so sometimes i still
can you know think this is like all
there is and it's real and get stressed
and everything but uh
yeah it gives you a different
perspective on things so just um
i'm really curious about how these
things work so um you invite people out
and then when when you're doing what
does the ceremony entail because people
call it a ceremony i kind of have this
idea i think a lot of people probably go
headdresses
full garb but i don't know if that's
reality
well what it is um first when you get
there there's like some initiations like
they tell you about the plan and what to
expect and all the which is great and
how to like integrate this how to handle
it when you go home because i didn't
really know that and i was like wanted
to tell everybody
and
they just can't relate to what you what
you're telling them they just thought
okay mate you you know you went in the
jungle they took some drugs and you
hallucinated
no just like i'm a celebrity i was there
i was like oh really this really
happened to me and
so you have to be careful how much you
tell people because otherwise they doubt
you
and when you when you see their doubt
they don't even need to say anything
like just the face right then you start
to think oh was it did i really have
that experience right um
so anyway
the ceremony itself um
is like i attract people there and i
maybe have a little chat with them or
something when we're there
um but the ceremony has nothing to do
with me because i'm not a shaman yeah i
go in there as a you know as a student
like everybody else
and you have a meeting with the shaman
before the ceremonies to say hey this is
me and
this is why i'm here this is what i'm
going to work on and
you know
they keep that in mind when they do the
ceremonies
and you go in and you have your place
like a
you know like a mattress or something
where you can
you're gonna sit and you go up one at a
time and you you take the drink the
medicine and you sit down and you wait
for the effects to stop
start
and then the shamans take over they
start to
these particular shamans are from the
shipibo tribe and they do
ikaros i think i hope i'm pronouncing it
right basically they're songs they're
spiritual songs so they'll see you
and they'll read you know once they're
in they take care of the plant medicine
themselves so the plant ayahuasca is not
just are you taking a drug it's some
kind of intelligence that i really
way more intelligent than us who knows
who you are
it knows why you're there it knows what
you need to learn
and
the shaman kind of works with that
energy and he'll sing songs for you
but they're for you for your
situation and then go to brian
and it'll be
helping brian with his situation often
you throw up you might [__] yourself
i heard people pissing themselves
laughing i've heard people crying i
heard women
having orgasms so all kind of stuff is
good
is it sorry but is this all at the same
time in a room then yeah there we're all
in the room together and it's and do you
have good cleaning stuff genuinely are
they are you conscious of the other
people in that moment or are you um yeah
you can kind of come in and out of it
you can hear stuff going on um but
within your own experience as well
and you can close your eyes or open your
eyes and you see
a lot of
symbolism
basically which is the structure of
reality is made up from numbers
i don't know if you heard of the
fibonacci sequence but you know starts
with one one and two and it's within all
structures of everything you see a lot
of numbers and shapes and colors and
messages and
uh
every experience is different and every
individual's experience is different and
it's frustratingly hard to describe yeah
no you i think you've done a good job
though i'm trying but it's an impossible
test to
to really describe it all um
did it make you want to change your life
after you had that experience then
every time is is different and
naturally is going to change anyway and
some stuff
came up that
uh i thought i had dealt with i thought
i'd processed it but it was still
still there on a deeper level and it
came out and
you know you're crying or screaming or
whatever you're just just getting it out
even when you're throwing up it's not a
physical thing it is obviously a
physical thing you're throwing up but
it's almost like you're purging out
negative emotions and things emotions
even get stored in your body you know a
lot often time when you get or probably
always there's a psychological
route to every kind of disease and pain
and everything like that so
people sometimes spontaneously healed or
the pain goes away because the emotion
has created that pain i have a friend
that practices a different kind of
medicine and has been very successful
and he's explained to me every cancer
has a trauma at some point in life that
was the root cause
and actually when you get cancerous the
trauma is
coming out
and
they don't use any medicine they they
process it out and it kind of goes away
we're here
you go to hospital i tell you got cancer
you sh
right into fear mode straight away all
right so and then they give you
toxic chemicals on top of that so
that's not going to go well if you know
how to handle it psychologically and
work through it at least that's
a new german medicine if anyone wants to
look that up it's very interesting
what's that is someone who's interested
in that what what kind of
new german medicine that's actually
literally what you
dr hammer right um it's not something i
practice but i've i've had conversations
with
with somebody that had three cancers and
they're still here that's fascinating
practicing this this is interesting
coming from you because you are a person
who's trial and error everything has to
be fact-based and backed up with data
and now a lot of the the stuff that
you're interested in um it's tricky to
prove isn't it it's it's you know there
are there is some evidence yeah you
can't put this in a box man yeah you
know uh so so the fact
black and white logical thinking dorian
is now a lot more flexible um
actually i had a lesson
um
because people know i'm i'm a cannabis
user and an advocate of cannabis and for
certain people certain situations maybe
and i've helped a few people i know
friends
with cannabis extract cannabis oil
to cure their cancers and you know this
is
fact i know them it's it's happened
so i went to one time i went to the um
ayahuasca and the shaman and had my
little consultation with him
and he looked at me and he said
you used a lot of coffee
i said no i don't drink coffee
he said cannabis
i said yeah
um
you need to use less
so there's me though you know
analytical logical less but how much but
when once a week twice a week what he
just laughed at me said wait
let's see that's that's the plan okay
how much were you smoking at the time do
you know i've released much smoke every
day like but not not really lots i'm
still
fairly disciplined with this as well as
like after my work's finished and
everything in the evening it's just like
somebody else might have a glass of wine
or whatever is you know go down the pub
and never want to drink i'll have a
joint that's it
and a little bit of um do you ever
combine it with a glass of wine sorry if
i combine it with a glass of water a
glass of red wine good shout out what a
combination
i have a couple little drops of the
extract before i go to bed yeah uh
anyway does that help though but uh for
sleeping the way the way it happens it
helps for sleep
and um
it's um
especially a preventative medicine
thc
is
very powerful
antioxidant anti-inflammatory
anti-cancer medicine
it's good for so many things
and don't have to take my word for it
guys if you go search a guy called
robert
i think i'm pronouncing it right he's a
molecular biologist
and his
field of expertise is free radicals
we're talking about exercise and free
radicals free radicals aging and
damaging your cells
and
uh he's the world's leading expert on it
and he says cannabis is
number one
uh
antioxidant
anti-inflammatory medicine that you can
take so anyway you know i got this love
affair with uh mary jane yeah cannabis
so he's telling me
you need to cut back a bit yeah
how much whatever it's like to laugh he
said just wait
just took the drink and you know so many
things going on so i'm just picking up
one thing that i remember
and uh
the plant was speaking to me in my mind
and it's always a female voice
and she said
you think about water is water good or
bad
water's good there's no life on a planet
without water and you know it's
essential right water water it's good
yeah so water's good
yes
okay
how about if you're [__] drowning in
it
oh
it's not so good then
so what i learned from that experience
is nothing is black and white nothing is
black and white and it changed the way i
think from being so
this is good this is bad this is black
this is why it just
made me realize that it's not like that
you know you've got to be a lot more
flexible in your thinking it was weird
for me when i watched that london reel
podcast the original one because
at the time i was really into
bodybuilding but i was also researching
911 and all these are and i have the guy
who i was aspiring to be like
in training come out with a lot of the
things i was researching it was like
[__] like this is like and the way and
you had your like [__] i i don't know
how there's anybody on the planet at
this point
doesn't know that 911 was a planned
demolition i mean it's so obvious and
there's so many people that were there
that were saying that
and a lot of those people had accidents
or were murdered
there's just so much when you look into
it it's blatantly obvious but these
people that
run the show they just think we're so
stupid well we are that's the problem so
stupid they they show us what they're
gonna do in movies and and tv they
always show you
before because there's a spiritual
aspect to this there's a karma
yeah there's karma attached but
in a way we've given them permission
we've said okay because they've showed
us
they've showed us what they're going to
do and we haven't protested and said no
don't do that
it's called predictive programming you
can go back and move is i was telling my
daughter years ago stop watching his
movies the hunger games and all these
games because every movie that's coming
out now for the young people is about
this dark dystopian future
it's like programming your mind that
this can and will happen
when the
pandemic that wasn't a pandemic started
um
i went on my apple boxer you know that
if you've got apple tv there's like the
top 40 movers or something what was it
really called pandemic yeah that was
like pandemic virus
[Applause]
so
over the years they've been preparing us
mentally for this that this could happen
and you could be in this
scary future where there's a virus
that's going to kill everybody everyone
at the time when it happened was saying
to me we're going to the lockdown and i
was like wait what the [__] a lockdown
like what like but everyone else was
like yep locked down look at that i also
remember what my experience was at that
time and i'll admit i there was a lot of
fear i had i had a pregnant uh wife and
my dad was very good it was very
seriously fear is the biggest weapon i
was very they were very serious ill and
i'll be honest i you know i i think
brian and i discussed this on a podcast
that kind of doubt for me it wasn't even
uh
from my perspective it wasn't me going
it's definitely a virus it's it's pretty
much i can't roll the dice with some of
these people in my life and i think they
play on those i some people play on
those aspects there's always a virus
sure
there's you know there's flu every year
somehow fluids fluidly disappeared
mutations are gonna yeah there's always
a virus so uh
if there was a pandemic
then surely the um
so called like the mean
uh all cause mortality or cause
mortality you know people that dying of
everything would go up right
it wasn't it's like 2020 is a little bit
less than 2019 and 2018. so in spain
there was a court case
somebody
took a case against the spanish
government the health
department of the spanish government
and said okay you you
did all these measures because of covert
19 right
okay so
can you show us proof
that kovit 19 exists and it has been
isolated as a you know partic virus
they didn't even turn up in court
so now all the fines in spain have to be
paid back
because there was no basis for the
lockdown in the first place
you're looking at the numbers boris's
father wrote a book about
uh how we need to reduce the population
through uh virus why am i not surprised
that uh one of the johnsons wrote that
yeah um that makes perfect sense they're
eurogenesis
no [__]
with the way they look as well isn't
that mental um
it should start at home but the no that
even no matter what what anyone believes
i always try and look at the numbers
and base my behavior off what the
numbers are saying and even if the
numbers are fake
it
you kind of even even if they are fake
you've got to look at the government go
your behavior does not match where we
are now even in your story it doesn't
even line up like 100 we're in between
100 and 200 deaths a day from corvid
how do we analyze that with a pcr test
that's absolutely useless exactly
but even if that is true
it doesn't make sense to be doing what
we're doing now right to me
because
we were like what was it
7 800 or whatever before we locked down
or whatever it was last time to be
acting like this before christmas now i
hear what we're saying they're coming
together
but
the credibility of the government you
know it surprised me how how many people
just sort of
abided by all the rules to start with
after they kept changing
are
literally hypnotized
they're hypnotized by the
propaganda and the tell lie vision
um
and they can't really think for
themselves and fear is like what happens
when you're really in fear you just
freeze
just freeze you can't do anything
literally freeze and that's that's the
mode that a lot of people are in they're
really they're really afraid and if you
dare to stick your neck up above
and go i don't agree with this you'll be
absolutely annihilated by p like the
regular people generally yeah
i don't agree with this yes or i want a
better explanation you just got to not
give a [__] about that
the main thing is it's always got to
like speak your truth that's it whatever
it is and
uh do you know that
sometimes though
what should we all do
dip our heads below the parapet so no
one can say anything and we just
keep on walking into this nightmare i've
got to meet there
when we're in a place and everybody
wakes up one day and say [__] what
happened what's happened to the world we
can't do anything we can't go anywhere
it's going to be too late so people need
to speak up now i also found people are
listening some people might
disagree with me but if there's one or
two people that's
like you know what i'm gonna look into
this a little bit more that's all i tell
people to do
do your research have a look into it
don't just
blindly follow and
do what you're told you know just like
60 million people were
killed in
in russia by the government
communism in china and the
whole part and you know it's happened
before the government's not your friend
and the government's supposed to be
there to serve us
not to dictate to us
all the time same as the police force
supposed to be there to serve the public
not to protect
uh
the elite which is what's happening now
basically that the foot soldiers
uh for the elite and that's where my
frustration comes from because after
researching 911 and realizing okay
whether or not it was an inside job
whoever did that
the government definitely covered it up
yeah they took the base out and they had
charges on everything yeah you watch any
demolition it's a 10 second to the to
the ground that is exactly what happened
with both the uh twin towers free fall
speed there is no fire in the world that
will grenfell's grenfell grenfell still
standing there you know what i mean it
didn't just come down in rubble and that
was an inferno a proper fire not a badly
burning fire at the top so when when
when your brain accepts that okay they
lied about this
i can't then trust them about anything
after that because that was one of the
words that was kind of like one of the
major steps to take us to where we are
now yeah
and i i told everybody like
because i used to go to the states a lot
and it all changed you know you can't
take your water on you're going to do
this you've got to go through the
scanner all that stuff
this is this is training stuff he's
hitting the double biceps in the sky to
be fair when they see when they see they
go you're going to have to get a scan i
don't go through the scanner right i
don't do it no
i don't go through there so you can
and you know they try to make it
inconvenient for it to not oh we're
going to do a body search okay wait
there they make you wait and then they
come along and they're like
you know your private area i'm going to
touch with the back of my hand and this
try to like make you feel uncomfortable
and humiliated so i just reverse it and
i'm like you're having a good time there
my balls a little massage thanks mate
you know
then they get uncomfortable right yeah
okay yeah yeah everything
so so yeah you you you started talking
about that on the brian rose podcast and
uh london reel he he then sort of that
that channel bloomed
off of that was the first time i'd ever
seen those two guys it actually used to
be two guys yeah there were two guys on
my first uh podcast
it was two guys yeah i just thought it
was just brian brian it's brian's thing
isn't it brian and uh nick
were
originally london real and the first one
i did right so these two guys who's nick
nick the best friend of bro or the he
was his jiu jitsu instructor i think
right and nick had um he was like they
were very different nick was the more
enlightened one brian was the business
banker never seen that before um and uh
and i loved that podcast and uh so
naturally i started watching more and um
nick basically got the boot
and brian
he has his story i think you can see
it's on youtube he talks all about that
and you know i don't know the ins and
outs of it but they were
a team the first one i did and then nick
was gone and you know i didn't think or
ask why really so you're saying the
co-host needs to be careful well i i
watched i said watch the nick the nick
story and he
he was less than complimentary of brian
he basically said we we started this
together
and then brian [__] me off as soon as
it started to get successful was it
brian isn't it ironically yeah
but the interesting thing was uh you he
asked you to do an interview recently
and
over the time
london real has been
um about
the journey and growing who you are and
then eventually it became an academy and
you you know he he would do this thing
where business could get a podcast on
youtube for free and then you'd have to
sign up to get the other half very smart
business model which is ironically what
he said to uh to me when i went on his
podcast and um i said look can i have
the whole thing to put on my channel at
a later date or whatever is it yeah yeah
and then after the fact i then asked him
for the whole thing he went no no no um
so that's why i removed our podcast for
those who wondered about brian rose
because it's the only podcast i've ever
taken down but then brian went into a
different direction
um uh which was um
the freedom platform and you get loads
of people that donate money for that now
was that with was that the one with
david ike yeah i think david like helped
him launch that um when he was doing the
whole ike rose three so there was i
crossed one there was um there were then
there was frost nixon two and then there
was i crossed so he inserted him he was
trying to grow his name off dave right
basically right um his freedom the
freedom platform got about a million
donations a million pounds worth of
donations no [__] way yeah and then
and then it never materialized yeah it
was more than that yeah so my my
experience with brian and london real
was the first one i did with brian and
nick
um
i think i did a second one then it came
to spain and did a documentary so you
know it was mutually beneficial
i had never done a podcast before
and uh
i didn't really like doing interviews
and i've done a thousands of interviews
and it's always the same bodybuilding
questions but what i liked about london
rail is we went off on tangents
and we you know we talked
but before we went on i was somehow came
up the conversation with psychedelics
and nick was like
can we ask you about this on i said he
asked me whatever you want you know i
don't really care
um
and it was super popular right it
boosted london real and it was good for
me as well
um
so it was all good
until and and brian
was very good at his jobs i think it was
a very good interview it had amazing
guests on there and uh i was actually me
that suggested hey take a look at this
guy david ike i think would be
interesting for your show and initially
didn't want to have him on there but
in the end he did
and whatever happened got tucked down
from youtube or
so it's like where we're going to fight
this censorship yeah and the whole thing
that was going on
with the pandemic and everything we're
going to fight this he made a lot of
videos at that time we're going to
create an army london real army and
everyone was behind it even me like yeah
that's a great idea let's all get
together and let's fight this is like
create the bloody a movement
and then there was like protests in
london with david eichen and different
people speaking and brian was
conspicuously absent
so i was thinking
are you really doing this
if it's not for your benefit and you're
not leading it you're not you're not
interested so you're not really
interested you're certainly making a lot
of videos but yeah so he was asking for
money to be donated
and everyone got behind it
friends of mine donated money because
with this cause cr you know build this
freedom platform and he spoke to me said
we're going to build this platform like
but why do you need all this money brian
to do the the podcast how because we
need to build the platform and it's not
going to be just for me i'm going to
build a platform like youtube but
everyone can use it and they can put on
there what they want you know it's going
to be a good idea freedom platform yeah
you know and i'm not tech savvy or
anything like that but some of my
friends were and they're like me
this guy hasn't created anything he's
just using existing platforms and not
even that expensive
so that was the first thing and some of
my friends then were
messaging him on instagram or where
wherever
basically asking like you know i donated
money i'm supporting you but i got some
questions
he was delete delete delete so the guy
that was fighting against censorship was
censoring his own followers
so i said freedom was a bit strange but
i still didn't really want to believe
that he was ripping people off there was
also the business courses that he said
the business courses i don't know too
much about terrible reviews
i made a lot of money from mine so the
joke's on youtube
basically because he spent a lot of time
with this dan pena this billionaire
creator he started doing his own
business courses started wearing dance
suits as well and then they did fit well
i don't know if they were good ideas but
but the guy was charging thousands and
thousands of pounds sometimes fifteen
thousand pounds for a business course i
think worth every penny for me
a lot of people were asking for their
money back and i've seen footage of
people in the street running up the
brine with a camera and he just
it's very political ironically denied
and i deny sort of thing and then after
he's
kind of burnt a few bridges there he
pivots again into politics and runs for
mayor
right after all that money had been
raised and a lot of people are like okay
so
you got a lot of money for the freedom
platform
that hasn't really materialized the way
we thought it would
and then you make a massive expensive
campaign for maya
that's when he contacted me to do
a further interview right so i know what
he wanted to do he wanted to interview
me so it would seem like i'm backing him
for mayor yeah and he said he was
second in the betting odds
but he basically put money on himself so
that's how he got up in the beta did you
see it do you see that interview where
he gets sort of rumbled where the guy
goes yeah but he goes we're second in
the odds and he goes have you put money
on yourself and he goes
i'm about to put money on myself because
if you have a massive bet come in that
you have to do you have to change well
the best one was with these young kids
that interviewed in the morning oh my
god yeah yeah they were like 15 years
old and they showed him up and he just
he had to get off it's time to go now i
i gotta go i got my they're telling me
bye-bye yeah that would be hard for you
though because you helped build this
creature and now
your name and your credibility as well
as many other guests that he's had yeah
he's helped create he had some amazing
guests on there it's such a shame
because he had a brilliant podcast he
was good at his job
this freedom
platform thing he could have really got
behind that and really started some
people were getting behind him
and so he asked me
can you do this interview i said i can
brian but i'm going to bring this up
because people ask him where's the money
at
ah
you know i don't really uh i can't
really address that i just want to talk
about my thing from there
i mean what i could have done really but
i could have just gone on there ambushed
him he said no i can't we'll address
this another day i said no i said if
that's
the way you want to do it mate i'm not
going to do the interview and then i
just put something on my instagram
saying guys
if you're you know looking forward to
the interview sorry i'm not doing it and
these are the reasons why
and i don't want to associate myself
with brian anymore because he can't
answer these questions even to me so
that was it with ryan it's a shame he
could have
it could have took it in a totally
different direction he's now into uh
crypto so he's pivoted again
and he's basically got the nickname
online as like the grifter who keeps on
griffin right okay and there's somebody
else out there that is going to be naive
and he'll be able to of course every
town needs a monorail yeah have you ever
seen that
[Music]
there's an episode of the simpsons where
there's a guy selling the monorail the
monorail monorail and then he goes to
like shelbyville and he goes to the next
town and he sells to make the same
crappy railway lighting
that's fantastic not saying that that's
brian rose of course we wouldn't i'm
actually just talking about a completely
unrelated episode of the synthesis but
not it's difficult it is a shame when
you've invested a piece of you and i
know how i felt about brian after he
told me one thing and then did a
completely different thing
you're like
nobody had a bigger impact on lunar real
than you like you're the reason i found
out who they were and now say like
what he's
allegedly how badly he's allegedly
trapped people and even that campaign
for mayor let's just speak facts it was
cringeworthy well
the problem with the camp what was the
bus called he had it he was in the back
of a bus with his pinstripe suit on
every day
taking calls and he's like hey everybody
he's getting no one viewing it no one
can you spend all that money that was
the problem and it was an ego trip
that's all it was but he did he's never
gonna win his real problem i think was
he ended up he ended up uh running for
mayor in the same year as
i think well two predominantly uh big
youtubers from the platform
did it for a joke and they got more
votes both of them got more votes than
brian rose he spent over apparently his
budge it was like the biggest budget in
like running for mia of london but
surely he must have known that he had no
chance i think i think he did but i
think this is the thing with him the way
he comes across anyway is like
just seeing his face on all those
billboards it got him off it must have
done something for him where because the
way brian grew his career was being the
other guy
so it's all about dorian it's all about
david like that's why when that's funny
because he made a documentary
about myself he came to spain to film
and all that stuff and so
we're having the premiere at the
the bafta buildings which was nice and i
bring all my
friends and family and
different guests and all that we're
watching it
and uh
i didn't see it before the premiere i
didn't particularly want to i said just
do what you want man i'll come and watch
it yeah and it started i'm like
it's all about brian at the start
so i used to be a banker and this and
that and that and first five minutes
where's the dorian then it okay then it
shifts into it but it's all it's all
about promoting himself exactly so
that's why when he did
the david ike interviews he called them
ike rose because what he's trying to do
is take from your stardom take from the
david like stardom and build him up
himself up but because he is
there's definitely skills there's a man
i'm not i'm not saying there isn't as
great as his job and because he wants to
be the star
i think this was his chance where he
thought i'm going to use this as a
springboard i won't win but i'll have my
face everywhere and that alone will be
the win and then i can pivot and bounce
off of that but it it just made him look
silly well brian you know he went to
saltara before me as i said that's how i
got connected with the sultan who did
his ayahuasca experience um
and the plant showed him lots of things
that he got to work on and this and that
and basically
he did none of them yeah you know so it
was kind of a waste of time and i just
think
um
i don't feel bad about it because
i got the the publicity as well it was
good for me got the word out there about
a lot of stuff your friends who lost
their money mate yeah i feel bad for
them and uh
i actually feel bad for brian because
he's got a lot of stuff he needs to work
on you know yeah really that's the way
i'm always left feeling with uh rose i i
i think there's a little bit of smoke
there's a guy with a lot of issues and
he still hasn't worked through it so
anyway i don't want to talk about brian
all day i think it's enough that we
spoke about it and cleared it up my
association with brian is
is no longer there
now you're this this new version of
dorian like i guess um you say you're
always evolving and i was wondering like
where your mind is at now with
everything that's going on in the world
and how you how do you see
things i believe now we're in a war it's
world war iii but it's just
not a physical war it's more like a
spiritual
war
and
it's like a
dark and light
thing
and
i i have faith in
god light universe whatever you call it
that
that ultimately that will prevail
um
[Music]
so that's where i'm putting my energy
and faith and uh
i'm doing my thing um
you know playing my part in this whole
kind of game that's going on what do you
what is your part um
just by being me and speaking the truth
uh
i think it has a domino effect on people
you can see what's going on and you're
getting all this information coming in
all the time and it's it's all
kind of intense negative right it can be
very negative yeah so i'm aware of
what's going on but i try not to let me
let it make me
be scared in the future we're all going
to be in camps if we don't have a v and
we're going to have digital passports
for everything and we have no freedom
i'm going to have no right to protest
and all these things that
is planned but i think their plans are
slowly going to fall apart
i feel like now we're getting to a point
with
people who in the past online i'd say
like
oh these people who aren't isolating and
they'd be the ones like doing the
basically
grassing people up for not isolating and
i'm seeing those people now turn on the
government now going [__] it i'm not
listening it's over it's done you know
what i mean like they're gonna have to
find a new reason other than save the
nhs which we've underfunded for best
part of god knows how many decades um
but
you do wonder that people just want to
be told what to do how many people
suffered
during the lockdown when they were
cancelling operations and not treating
patients and all this stuff cancer
patients and the old people they were
giving end-of-life care to basically
seeing them off with the
benzodiazepines and uh
morphine and stuff like that it's come
out now i can't remember the name of the
drug but it's like a super strong
benzo that they were giving
people in the care homes all people are
just basically killing them off
i think more and more people who
originally are skeptical of the david
ikes out there and whoever else um are
now coming around at least saying this
is getting weird huh like because we all
got um
a version of reality that we think the
way the world is and it operates by the
information that
we've got right from life experiences
from school from the media from the tv
so we're given a picture
um we think that's the way things are
and if somebody comes along and says no
it's not like that that's all upside
down
it's very hard to take in at first even
if you're kind of an open person when i
started coming across some information i
was like wow don't know about that but
then you know you see more and more and
you just accept that
uh the world is different from the way
that we thought it was when when you
started researching
your
um
you know
discovering a lot of these things what
was the one that shocked you the most
can you remember the thing that was like
that's the penny dropping that's the
moment that dorian is never going to be
the same now he knows that
i had a friend that was
serbian so
i'm watching cnn or what's going on in
the uh balkans war
and it's telling me like mate my
family's there that's not like that so
i used to believe everything that i saw
on the news surely it must be yeah like
that now i don't even look to be honest
but if i do i can read between the lines
and have a laugh about it
kosovo is actually quite an interesting
place to go to yeah and we're saying the
news is almost exposing itself now
because
independent um
people are now growing in power like joe
rogan for example
and people are switching off yeah
switching off that's what's going on and
that's why cnn are attacking joel i love
the speech that ricky gervais gave at
this whatever award oh yes brilliant
because he's just you know
dressed up as a
as a joke he's telling the truth yeah
and a lot of these things are going to
come out with this uh
child trafficking and pedophilia right
now is the biggest
trial
which is in jason giselle design oh yeah
gulen gillen i think is the bbc have had
to learn state as well so yeah but uh
it's hardly being covered right yeah
yeah wait isn't it hardly been covered
it's almost like that they're putting
the right the most pizza put the right
judge in place and all this so i don't
know
if the truth will come out of that but
that's you know andrew must be sweating
on it all the uh
such andrews like
like a lot of the elite politicians and
so on was going out to that island
yeah if you look at the book you look at
the flying log
bill clinton clinton really likes flying
so does donald trump by the way
you know these people
they're different to us they're deeply
evil they're psychopathic so they can do
things that we wouldn't
wouldn't dream of doing for them they
don't have a psychopath doesn't have
empathy so
and that's the thing is to push a button
to to go
to
know that
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to lose their lives innocent
people a lot you know who aren't even
signing up for it yeah you have to be a
certain kind of guy you
and i think a lot of women right yeah a
lot of regular people we think oh yeah
well that's what their job is they're
politicians but
we disconnect from them being they're
people and you have to think what kind
of person can do that what kind of
person wants to have all that power do
you have to be conditioned maybe maybe
you go to a school where you're sort of
taught those things and you i mean you
know i think you have to be like hillary
clinton and people like that you have to
be able to completely disconnect from
human life and not care and that's to me
what these people are like that is
partly what i find interesting actually
because i do think the the british
britain's much smaller island so it's
much more uh sometimes a bit more
difficult to hide away from the it's
quite an intense media we've got here
right and i do think during kovic quite
quite a few of those masks have slipped
and people have seen elements of the
government
being actually quite [__] at their job
in the first place have you ever seen
how many projects pretending that
they're pretending to be incompetent so
we just are they're just stupid muppets
but no no they're not well you see
that's why that's why i actually find
another reason they have a plan yeah
that's actually kind of what i find
interesting because i think a lot of you
know
boris and who doesn't know what he's
doing he knows what it is pretty much
yeah
another real shock names another real
shock was how many protests during the
this um covered period we're not even
going we're not covered and i'm talking
when you do see the video of them on a
social media you're like wow like these
are this is like tens of thousands tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands and
not not one media outlet is even
mentioning it and that's when you go
are you still going to believe what this
law is saying because news is news it's
not well we cover this so we don't cover
that nearest this new year
yeah if they showed
hundreds of thousands of people have
come together
very peacefully
to make a protest
people might think you know what they've
got a point i'll join them if you don't
know about it you can't you know exactly
i've actually i've i've not been to
those protests um
just have been busy but
there were
it's true but i'll get my nails done
i've been i've been caught i've been
sort of caught by them or they've passed
by and i i did a walk with yeah and my
daughter tani and she's been with her
friends as well
and uh not when i was there but when my
daughter was there she saw the police
running into a peaceful cloud and just
start beating people yeah and then they
say
these
extremist anti-vaxxer protesters were
violent
no the protests before the whatever is
black lives matter and antifa they were
violent and you just sit back and let
them
go ahead it's clever how they reframe it
and call it like because you could be
anti-lockdown
and not anti-vaxx but they but then i'm
not answering anything but anti-vaxx
it's that it's a dirty word isn't it
where they make you
separate
yeah yeah i'm not hunting anything i'm
just pro-truth
yeah pro-truth and pro-freedom freedom
of choice especially and i think the
fact that we're now getting to a point
where all right they're not saying
everyone is going to be pinned down and
vaccinated but they're making life as
difficult as possible for you to live
without that vaccine is the same thing
almost yeah because they're very
concerned about your health apparently
yeah they really were concerned when
they were to iraq and there was turns
out there was no weapons of mass
destruction but it was worth
losing so many thousands
after this george bush was even making a
joke about it yeah he was doing a speech
and he's like hold on where's the
weapons of mass destruction are they
here are there underneath a joke with
his mates
we were in the uh we went to an award
show where tony blair was there once and
i've never been in a room before with
someone who looks quite as evil and like
you know when they say like the life you
live turns up on your face almost like
you you you look quite stress-free
dorian this man looked
pure he looks like he belonged in star
wars didn't he do you know what i'm
saying it wasn't take a look at him when
he's younger
but there's
there's a spiritual aspect to this
which you know it could go in a deep
rabbit hole and might lose some people's
interest
entities
there's
powers that live outside our vision that
these people that's why they do this
atlantic ritual so they can tune into
this and and basically the way i see it
is like
if you get deep into this you can have
whatever you want
in this physical world
um
but you're paying a price and you can
see it in the in the eyes the guy has
lost his soul basically if you want to
put it like that there's there's a lot
of celebrities who do this picture where
they cover one eye as a saying that
we're in the club sort of thing right
yeah we should just do that compromised
because they've been put in compromising
positions
like this guy epstein and maxwell
provide this underage girls or whatever
it is that goes worse than that but
and then they'll probably be filmed or
photographed doing all this stuff so
well absolutely
everywhere
sorry what's worse than them
uh the sacrificial right of the children
you know the sacrificial
ceremonies and stuff you just check out
how many children go missing every year
i don't know in the uk a couple hundred
thousand children go missing every year
they don't turn up anywhere i didn't
know where they go it's incredible yeah
right
i didn't know it was that high that was
amazing
i don't know the exact thing right it's
funny very high yeah
it's it's ironic because obviously like
i said i don't believe everything david
like says but
years ago he was banging on about this
and he was saying like they're going
away to
even alex jones i remember him coming up
with a phrase pedo island
and and and people are like oh yeah as
if they've got an island they all fly
over to and then you know years later
the epstein case comes out and it's
basically nailed on what that was i
remember one of the books i read earlier
once from david i was like an eyewitness
that was at some
ceremony with edward heath who was prime
minister at the time
and they were you know they're
sacrificing kids and stuff and i thought
that's far out yeah
and then i saw an interview
fairly recently with a policeman
who's now whistleblower
he was um
used to work as you know outside downing
street
and they said at two o'clock three or
four times a week two o'clock two a.m in
the night a car would roll up and
four or five six-year-old boys would
come out
and they'd have to take them in because
you know there's processes right and
they'd be there for a couple hours and
then
shipped off again
so they knew what was going on and he
was a well-known um
pedo wasn't it edward heath was that
come proven though
well this was you know he was there he
said he saw it and he said
what should we do
what what can we do you know um
if we go tell the higher-ups maybe
they're just going to move us on anyway
so let's have a word with him he said we
spoke to him and said sir this
whatever's going on like we know we're
seeing it and it's got to stop
so it said it stopped and about two
weeks later they were
sent somewhere else and that's
supposedly how um jimmy savile
remained safe for as long as he did is
because
he was a facilitator yeah so all of
these um kids hospitals and all of that
that he'd set up the whole charity thing
for him was a way of hiding a way of
putting up almost a protective
shield that i'm the charity guy you know
and all of you know everyone's like that
yeah yeah somebody's reaching for
actually raising money for charity right
now quite literally genuinely yeah but
he he used this as a way of according to
david like procuring
the kids for these higher ups and when
you say jimmy savile the radio dj
photograph with all these royals and all
these political people like thatcher
you're like why was this guy so
in in with them and then you know it all
comes out after he's done it now it's
obvious right yeah
[__] nothing comes out until people
have passed away if they're protected
yeah yeah it might come out after the
fact cyril smith the
you know the uh liberal guy a big fat
politician that was in the liberal party
it's all come out about him now but he's
it's not here anymore
[__] no
you're quite a prominent figure though
does it never um
do you never feel an element of concern
for your own sort of safety within that
well for speaking out yeah this isn't a
threat though i'm just asking i don't
think i'm
really big enough to be concerned about
that i mean if you're gonna
be afraid
to speak your mind what's what's the
point you know right again into that
fear mode again you should be able to
freely speak
uh
what you think and everybody should be
able to do that and there's so much
control it's been getting more and more
intense almost like
controlling what people think or trying
and how they speak speak you know you
can't it's not politically correct
that's the truth
you know it's offensive
[__] everyone's offended now but it's
social engineering it's engineering the
way that we even think it's through the
media and the tv and the movies and what
have you it's uh in schools i feel like
men like yourself and and i'd class
myself as a similar kind of guy like
it's a dying breed and it it it's um
it's very much like it's seen as a bad
thing almost and you've got this new
word called toxic masculinity i was
thinking of that myself yeah and and
don't get me wrong like
anything can be toxic anything can but
that word alone it's it's almost
suggesting if you're too masculine
that's a bad thing well two anything is
about exactly but so by its very nature
it's a stupid word um because what you
should just say is like massive
someone's an [__] you know what i
mean or whatever but
it does feel like now you know my
experience on social media is if i if i
speak out and say anything that is a bit
too
self-assured
and and and
show signs of being an alpha male
it is a bad thing now people react in a
bad way and
i'm [__] pissed off with it if i'm
honestly it's annoying [__] them be who
you are you know that's
that's what i'm saying there's pressure
to to mold people and mold the way that
they think and the way they behave
and
you just got to
break that and and be who you are but
can i just interject on that i think i
kind of i kind of agree in my experience
to be the same obviously not necessarily
embodying the classic alpha male ideas
but um
what i do find interesting and i think a
lot of people um
hear what you say
and they say um and you're saying be
yourself and i i think that's a really
great message but what that we we i
almost want to go a step further and say
when you are yourself and when you are
honest and when you are saying what you
really think you'll actually get very
honest feedback from the world as well
you're not basically saying go out and
[__] everyone else you can think
whatever you want and that won't change
you you're saying that if you are you're
i don't want to put words in your mouth
i'm kind of putting the theory out there
if you are yourself then through those
experiences you will learn um
you'll also learn about yourself and the
world will reflect back to you so if you
are wrong about something or you know
you put an if you put an opinion out
there
you'll get feedback on that yeah and
that and that that changes you as a
person and you adapt but it's why that
feedback's coming is the question
but i'm not saying that feedback won't
always be negative it's the same thing
with me with bodybuilding i might have
perceived and maybe i did for some
period of time
that people expect me to be this guy
right
so
i should be this guy to keep everybody
happy no be yourself and what i learned
is like
actually
more people follow me now
because i'm just
being genuine and in this world which is
full of [__]
people find
they pick up on that there's something
different it's a guy
being genuine and they relate to it
people know when you're bullshitting and
i know when you're being genuine
instinctively they know that and i think
they find it refreshing if somebody's
honest
and ultimately you can't think well how
should i behave
to keep everybody happy you'll never
keep everybody happy anyway
so be yourself and that's the word
oh i can't say this i can't do that
because i might upset somebody or it's
not the trend at the moment
that's how we're controlled
you know it's almost like you don't need
a sheepdog to keep all the sheep
because they'll do it themselves when
you step out of line everybody
starts no no no no no no you know don't
do this don't dress like that don't do
that and then you think oh to fit in i
better
stay within the herd what do you what
can i say one thing i'm struggling with
right now online is like is kind of what
you're getting up there is
there's people who are searching for
reality the truth information knowledge
and there are some people online the
vast majority who want to listen to
things that make them feel better about
their life feel better about them and it
not not necessarily care about being
real but just want to hear nice things
and those people when they are hit with
a character like myself or or many other
people out there
they they [__] flip out they're like
oh this is this is in and they're
offended and they try and shout you down
and they try and organize things to take
you down and
and there's a lot of that um council
culture out there right now council
culture a lot of the time or
people offended by someone speaking the
truth um
you know and they
they can't a lot of these [__] who
haven't got the balls to stand up and be
counted would rather have that person
who has that strength not there anymore
so they can go back to feeling yeah
making them feel uncomfortable and and
i'm [__] i'm really fed up with that
[__] um and i think that that
unfortunately is like this i'm offended
thing online right now it's getting
bigger and stronger and stronger and
people who i used to know who were part
of the the stand-up recounted guys are
now on that side and they're doing again
they've been
beaten yeah into although they want to
be on the winning team and they want to
be seen as the knight in shining armor
but they even i almost feel more
disappointed a lot of people just want
to fit in yeah they don't want to be
you know ostracized and feel they don't
fit in and so on um
fortunately that never concerned me
about trying to please people or fit in
i don't want to
go out my way to hurt anybody or
anything like that but if what i'm
saying is just my opinion you're
offended then
tough [__] really like if i'm watching a
youtube video and i and i don't like
what i'm saying turn it off i'll turn it
off i won't leave [__] little comments
no i get i get people majority people on
my social media is very positive but
there's always somebody you know yeah
and i just think you know
why have you taken time out of your day
yeah
so come on my page if you don't like
what i'm saying or don't like me
whatever
and taking your time out of your day to
to make a post about it because they're
they're upset dorian they're all upset
well go somewhere else
go somewhere else if you're upset
obviously
you could disagree with me
by all means yeah of course i might be
wrong as well i might next week so you
know what brian
i i thought this well i found this so i
changed my mind now have you found that
a lot in your in your journey
sometimes yeah you're constantly
evolving so
what you might have thought
before you might find some new
information and modify your viewpoint so
ah
everyone can be wrong right nobody's
right all the time that would be
impossible because i'd imagine they're
also being right all the time just
expressing your
uh
your view and your opinion how you feel
right now everybody should be able to do
that that is part of council culture i
think um
it encourages less people to take a shot
at least at being right or at least
putting their opinion out there
just in case you put it on your page and
everyone's you're an [__] you're
wrong
well that's part of it and that's kind
of what i do appreciate i you know i
mean going further back the men who
so
who weren't this unoffended like you
know culture those were the men that
went to war those were the men that
saved this country from you know losing
our freedoms and stuff like that those
were the standard be counted kind of
guys and those are exactly the kind of
guys who are barely around anymore if
you can
suppress the male and control the male
then you can control
the rest of the society because they're
the guys at the front they're the
warriors you know the women the female
and the male
both have their roles to play but that's
the male role was always to provide and
protect for for the family so if you
move the male out of the equation
and
break up the family then you've got a
lot of dysfunctional
other males growing up that are easier
to control so it's it's you know it's a
planned effort it's not something that's
just spontaneously happening through
society
it's uh
it's a planned assault
so we'll be easier to control like like
now i think we're about to wrap this up
now you've got uh you've got family here
so we'll do that yeah last question is
always the same uh
how would you like to be remembered
um
frank sinatra song
did it my way
that's it
did it my way did
live my life the way i wanted to live it
and hopefully inspire other people to do
the same
that was dory nate on the true jordi
podcast uh great to have another one of
me uh idols on here and uh we'll put the
links in the description below for diy
nutrition you've got your own supplement
company you're on tour you've been
smashing that lately yeah i've just done
two-week tour of the whole
uk a lot of the
big gyms have been from durham
all the way down here back to the
midlands back down here again
so that's finished i'm spending some
time with my daughter now chilling out
and uh
on friday go to glasgow doing a little
training camp up there and then
back out to spain for uh for christmas
awesome oh well i'll put the links for
dorian socials below as well if you want
to follow the man
the legend dorian yeah do so and uh
thanks for watching thanks for having me
on mate thanks a lot thank you
appreciate it see you later